Is the mist attack after is the missed
attack? How we might find social
cohesion today in Europe? We got to go
back to the beginning to
Muhammad. Now, here's the first
interesting thing that a few people
understand. From 632, the year Muhammad
died, one century later, 732, Muslims
are now in the middle of Europe fighting
and abducting people and destroying
churches. They found what they want to
claim is this great time of tolerance
and beauty, but they're acting like ISIS
on steroids. They symbolically were
trying to denigrate Christianity but we
don't talk about that. In one century
from M's death they conquered
threearters of the original Christian
world permanently. This is what's
building up towards the first crusade.
So uh then let's go to the crusades. You
hear the word crusade. It's such a
diabolical evil thing, evil venture. Now
what they don't tell you, okay, is one
that's how effective they've been.
They've gotten that narrative to become
dominant. Maybe we just stick with 2025
and what's happening. We've had some
reports from Congo, Nigeria. I think
every week I have to read about dozens
of Christians being killed. And of
course the media, they they tell you,
"No, no, this is a this is about climate
change." But they actually do that. I've
noticed and I've been following this and
writing about it a lot. Muslim
persecution of Christians has been one
of those most no topics. We don't want
to we don't want to go there. make it
relevant to what's going on in that
because you're sort of given a
historical context. Germany, Muslims are
going to be like 40% of the population.
I mean, at that point, yeah, it's going
to be
like Raymond Ibraham, thank you so much
for coming to speak with me on this
show. There's two topics I'm keen to get
into with you. You've done an amazing
documentation of the persecution of
Christians by Muslims in Africa and
around the world and you've been doing
that for some time. You're also a
prolific historian uh documenting not
only Islam in Europe and but Islam
around the world. Um before we get into
those things, I wondered if you could
tell me a little bit about yourself and
tell viewers a bit about yourself and
also why you call yourself cancelled on
your YouTube bio. Uh well, thanks Win
Winston. It's great to be with you. A
little bit back background on myself is
um I'm of Egyptian heritage descent,
Coptic specifically. My family left
Egypt I think in the very late 60s. I
was born here um
73 and um so it kind of gave me an
advantage. I was bilingual. I grew up
speaking Arabic of a certain dialect
anyway. Then I studied it formally in
English and obviously I had an interest
in sort of the nexus of Western
civilization and Islam because of my
Christian background. I sort of
gravitated to Western civilization
obviously. Um but I was very familiar
with Islam and Egypt and my family and
the background. So I've always been
interested in that. And then in college,
uh, I actually majored in history with a
focus on actually I started off with
classics, but then I delved into the
Middle Ages, medieval Islam and, uh,
Byzantium, Eastern Roman Empire. And,
um, you know, you may know the name
Victor Davis Hansen. He was my professor
actually back way back then. We were
still good friends. He writes forwards
for my books. Great guy. Um but you know
he also got me interested in military
history because before he became the
prolific commentator about everything he
was a military historian and so my first
my master's thesis was about the first
major battle between Christian Muslim
armies major battle of the battle of
Yarmmuk in 636. So that was my MA thesis
and then since then I've been um very
much I continued being very interested
in the history but then I long story
short after 9/11 I got another I went to
Georgetown University and I was accepted
there and I also attended a PhD program
but I ended up leaving. I had straight
A's because I got a full-time job at the
Library of Congress and then I got a
major book deal. Uh my first book was
the al-Qaeda reader. I actually came
across writings by al-Qaeda in early
2000 when I was working at the Library
of Congress that had not even been
cataloged. Um, so we actually that was
turned into my first book that came out.
And that's why because of all that
full-time job and writing a book, I
essentially couldn't I was also told uh
Victor Hansen made a good point. He told
me if you know you're you already got
what most people who are trying to get a
PhD want, okay? Like books and deals and
you're also at a point with what you've
said and the position you've taken. even
if you get a PhD, nobody's going to hire
you because they're all left-wing
universities and you're, you know,
you're just they're not, they don't want
your views there. So, that was another
reason for me not to even bother with
it. Um, and then soon after around 2008
or nine, I essentially resigned from the
Library of Congress. It was a great job.
I was like a kid in a playground because
I had access to all these very arcane
esoteric books. But um and I've been a
fellow at various think tanks since then
uh including the Gatesstone Institute,
the Middle East forum. Um I was for a
while at the Hoover Institute, etc. And
um that's it. Since then, I've also kind
of gravitated back to my to my original
academic interests, which is history. So
my more recent books, one of them 2013,
I wrote Crucified Again, exposing
Islam's new war on Christians, which
pertains to what we'll be talking about.
It's about the persecution of Christians
in the modern era. And then in 2018, I
wrote uh Sword and Scimitar, 14
centuries of war between Islam and the
West, which you might call my um Magnism
Opus because it's like this is what I
was studying for over 20 years. It's the
continuation of the battle of Yarmmuk.
So that's chapter one, battle of
Yarmmuk. And then I go through all the
other major encounters and wars all the
way up until America's first war with
Islam. It's first war as a nation
actually, the Barbary Wars. Um and that
book's done very well and it's been very
controversial. You know, I was invited
by the war US Army war college to give a
talk about it and then I don't know if
you know care the council on they went
ballistic and the council of council on
Americans and Islamic relations which is
like a brotherhood wing and um Muslim
Brotherhood. Yeah, Muslim Brotherhood.
And uh they actually got me um they they
shamed the US Army War College in
rescending my invitation by calling them
racist and I was a racist and a white
supremacist and it was just so childish
and immature. the US Army War College
basically buckled and but the good news
is a lot of people when they some media
reported on it a lot of people actually
came on my side and totally shamed them
and parents wanted to withdraw their
kids out of it and several congressmen
sent a letter to Trump about it and then
you know the all kinds of organizations
got so they reinvited me
uncancled and yeah I was uncancled and
if anything they told me it was the
second largest event since a Buzz Aldrin
event they had Yeah, thanks to care,
right, for creating all that
controversy. Everyone wanted to see what
this is about, right? All publicity is
good publicity, it turns out. Yeah. So,
that's anyway, that's a little aside.
And then um the other book I wrote,
which is also very popular, also
historicals, defenders of the West, the
Christian heroes who stood against Islam
where I just look at uh eight
biographies of kings and warriors and
warlords who actually fought against
Islam. And people really like it because
it's it's such a different story than
what you're told. One of them is
Dracula, Vlad Tempus, Vlad the Impaler,
who of course is the most demonized, and
people are like, "How would you put him
in the book, but if you look at the
sources, yeah, he was he identified as a
Christian, Orthodox, and um he fought
against Islam, and he was and he was
basically um the impalement, and we can
even get into that. That was his way of
it was a tit for tat. That's what they
were doing. He learned that as a hostage
of the Ottomans, the Turks. He watched
them impale his own people. So, this was
his own way of fighting them back."
Anyway, so and that gives you an idea of
so much of what I try to do is um give
context and correctives to what we think
we know about history and a lot of it we
don't like the Crusades. Um a lot of
people you know think the Crusades,
okay, these are evil ventures, white
supremacist going to colonize some poor
nation and you know it's completely
different and we'll probably get into
that. Well, the Crusades are back in the
news because Pete Hgset has got a
Crusade cross blazed across his right
and I've spoken a lot about that and but
he's he's in the news more recently for
another tattoo. He's in the news always
for his tattoos, an Arabic tattoo of the
word keir which means uh I it's usually
translated as infidel but it means it's
a non it means non-Muslim but it has all
these negative associations with it. So
it's a pjorative. It's a complete
porative. I mean, it's synonymous with
subhuman, you know, enemy, God hates
you, we should kill you. That's what the
word means, but it gets translated in
English Qurans as unbeliever, very
neutral sounding. Um, so anyway, he, and
it's funny, why are Muslims angry that
he has the word keer written on? He's an
infidel, right? They should, that's what
Islam makes him, but they're angry
because he's proud of it. You're a keer,
you should be embarrassed and ashamed.
But he's flaunting it. He's he has it as
a tattoo. He has it as a badge of honor,
literally. Do we know where when he got
that tattoo? No, I don't I don't I don't
know. And I don't know if anyone does
because all every time we see these
tattoos, he doesn't talk about him. They
just capture some weird picture of him
and you can see a tattoo and then they
start talking about the tattoo because
they finally saw it. So, I don't know,
right? Maybe he's been reading your
books. Maybe. Maybe. Um but anyway,
yeah, that recaps it with me. So, and
then since then, I'm just um writing my
books and um I'm still a fellow of think
tanks. I'm writing articles and I'm
trying to develop my YouTube channel.
trying to do what you do very modestly
at this point. Uh which is fun. Uh it's
fun. It's amazing to me because when I
write an article and even it appears in
pretty good websites, you know, you can
tell how many views there are via
comments, maybe 20 comments, 30
comments, but I make a little video on
YouTube and there's like 300 comments.
So, you know, I guess that's the way to
go. More people are interested in
watching than reading. Yeah.
Generational thing. And I'm happy to
oblige. Well, look, you've you've
mentioned the battle of Yarmmuk twice
and perhaps before we we go into what's
going into Europe, maybe well, maybe
this is the starting point. So, what's
happening at the battle of Yarmuk then?
The interest to me in the battle of
Yarmmuk is it it's the genesis of the
conflict between Christendom and Islam.
That's really its significance. Um, and
so basically, we got to go back to the
beginning to Muhammad, right? Muhammad's
dead 632 and now you have what's called
the Ridda wars which is uh after he died
a lot of Arabian tribes tried to break
away from the fold of Islam and the
first khalif Abu Bakr launched these
apostasy wars which is very interesting
because even till this day Muslim
clerics will tell you without the law of
apostasy which is you kill anyone who
tries to leave Islam Islam would have
died out I mean that they actually say
that they admit it that's why we have to
have the apostasy law because if people
have freedom to leave it will go will be
gone. So those that the the the culture
of apostasy, punishing apostasy didn't
exist before then under Muhammad. No,
no, it did. He's the one who Yeah. It
goes to a hadith, a statement attributed
to him, which is considered canonical in
Sah Bkari where he says literally um
whoever leaves his religion, meaning
Islam, kill him. Mhm. So that was always
part of the religion according to that
teaching that hadith and that's why it's
still there. Okay. So by the second
generation of Muslim leaders, they're
now codifying that and yeah, well when
and how Islamic law gets codified is
kind of a controversial thing depending
on which version you want to go to, but
much most most most of you it's happens
much later after Muhammad. Uh maybe like
he dies 632. Really the first writings
and the hadith are maybe around 750. And
this is why there's a school of thought
that says Muhammad never existed and it
was all fabricated later to give a
hographical foundational story to the um
empire. Um but at any rate so you have
now the Muslim uh the Muslim power is
consolidated on Darbu Bakr and then
later the other Khalif Omar um who are
companions and friends of Muhammad and
now the jihad is waged in earnest. Now,
here's the first interesting thing that
few people understand. In 632, you know,
if I talk to someone, your average
person, and I talk about the Middle East
or North Africa, and they know it's
Muslim, they don't know how it got
Muslim. They think it's always been
Muslim. in the in the dawn of Islam
during this time that I'm discussing 632
and so forth the eastern world Egypt
greater Syria as it was called which
encompassed modern day Israel Jordan
Lebanon it was a big chunk um Anatolia
or Turkey what we call Turkey and like I
said Egypt all the way down to Morocco
Moritanium and you you know and
Augustine's hippo was there in Tunisia
all that was actually more Christian
than Europe so if you talked about
Christianity at the dawn of Islam you
were talking about Egypt, you were
talking about Syria, you're talking
about Asia Minor, Greece, of course, and
Europe. But Europe was actually less
Christian. And of course, anything
northwest of the Danub brine was still
not even Germany. You know, the
Scandinavian lands hadn't even reached
Christianity at that point. Um, and this
is why the Roman Emperor
Constantine moved the capital of Rome,
New Rome, Constant Constantinople, to
the east because that's where everything
was. That's where the learning was.
That's where the sophisticated culture
was, the wealth. All right? Uh and
again, when people, we have records of
people traveling through Egypt and they
say all we heard from the top of the
Nile to the bottom is just hymns and
church bells, etc. This is before Islam.
Same thing with Syria. Okay? So people
miss this context. This is what the
Middle East was. If you wanted to talk
about Christianity, there were five
major centers. Okay? They call them
seas. One was Rome and the other four
were in the Middle East. Okay? One was
Alexandria, one was Antioch, one was
Jerusalem, and then later
Constantinople. All east and all
conquered by Islam. Okay, which we'll
get into. So anyway, we have the first
major attack. Um, and we have the battle
of Yarmmuk in 636 and the the Muslims
prevail. Where is Yarmmuk? Yeah, Yarmmuk
is a river in Syria. Um, or it was in
greater Syria at the time, so I don't
know if it's in part of Jordan now, but
I'm pretty sure it's in Syria still. Um,
and that's where the two major armies,
the Eastern Roman Empire, which they
call Byzantium. I sort of don't like
that word because it sort of creates a
discontinuity between the Roman Empire,
that's they saw themselves as Romans.
Even the Arab accounts call them Romans,
you know. So, this word Byzantine, I
just anyway, but it's short, it's easy,
it's succinct. So I'll use I do I
interchange them but the Eastern Roman
Empire basically and the Arabs the
Muslims bought fought there and there
was a major epic confrontations and the
Christians lost and for various reasons
among it you know there was a death
desert storm which they weren't used to
fighting in whereas the Arabs were and
it takes on a great you know it's very
hographical tradition amongst Arabs it's
this is you know where it all begins and
this is where Allah proved he was for us
because we beat the infidels
etc., etc. And you know, I I won't get
into it, but anyone who's interested
really should read about the battle
because a lot of what you know, ISIS,
the Islamic State, the stuff they would
say, which sort of sounds cryptic and
people didn't understand it, they would
say things like, um, "We've tasted
American blood and none is sweeter and
people just thought they were being
gross." Actually they were quoting
characters from the battle of Yarmmuk
Muslim heroes specifically bin Alid
known as the sword of Allah who said to
the Romans we've tasted Roman blood and
none is sweeter. All right so when a lot
of the things they would say is actually
from that battle and other battles as
well but that's how you know these these
battles and major confrontations with
the Christian world where they prevailed
still figure prominently in their
historical consciousness whereas to most
westerners they have no clue. Right.
Yeah. Um so at any rate the battle
happens the the west uh the the the
Christians lose and now begins the great
takeover of the of the Middle East. All
right. Egypt which was a major center
for the Roman Empire gets conquered four
years later uh right or 5 years around
640 641 and you know the they continue
marching all the way west until they get
to Morocco around 690. They take over
Carthage you know where um and Augustine
and Hippo. So all these major centers
and in Syria as well completely
conquered. Jerusalem is conquered one
year after Yarmmuk, right? It's like a
complete domino effect. And there's
theories of why this is. One of them is
the is that the Byzantine Empire was
very weakened at the time. But also the
Muslims enter and conquer Persia, the
Cassanian Empire at the time. Okay. And
now it's in now Iran's been conquered
and they continue eastward. But just to
you know just to for brevity sake I'll
continue focusing on the western
Christian world. Um and so now so from
632 the year Muhammad died one century
later 732 Muslims are now in the middle
of Europe fighting and abducting people
and destroying churches. Not just the
middle of Europe as far north in France.
That's why I'm Yeah, that's the date.
732 is the battle of Tours which is
right in the heart of France. Spain has
been conquered since 7-Eleven. Okay. And
now they, you know, after they they took
over Morocco, now they sailed into Spain
and that was completely conquered and
devastated and now they're in the middle
of France, okay, attacking and and this
is the battle of Tor. So in one year, in
one century from Mama's death and
historians have actually quantified it,
but it's basically they conquered
threearters of the original Christian
world permanently. Wow. In Spain, not
permanently, but for like eight
centuries they were there. And of course
in France they still continued
depradations and the Mediterranean
islands were all conquered around the
8th century you know Sicily and uh Malta
and and all of them Cyprus and and um
roads for centuries. Um and again it's
to me I'm just baffled at how people
don't understand these were not just
Christian countries. These were the main
Christian countries and they just gone
conquered and Islamized and nobody knows
this. If you talk about those countries
now like Egypt or Syria, most people
just have this vague notion they were
always Muslim and you know Muslim just
spread Islam spread there. No. And again
if you look at the sources both the
Arabic and Islamic and the European
chronicles they make it unequivocally
clear this was violent bloodshed
conquest. And it's even worse in the
Arabic recordings because they boast
about it. the more violent it is and the
more you know the atrocities committed
against the Christian infidels and the
more churches destroyed. This is more a
reflection of how pious the Muslim
conquerors were. So it's actually worse
in the Arab I always find this amazing
that it's more graphic sometimes than
the European ones which are a little
more objective. They say yes we were
attacked and thousands were butchered
and enslaved and churches but the the
Muslim ones revel in it. Okay. And so
now let's just stop for a moment. None
of this is being taught in any school at
all. Can I just ask do you have a sense
of the death toll in that first century?
Uh no. I mean these unfortunately
seventh century is what we're talking
about. We're lucky to have just the
records that we have. But and I know I
put it in sword and scimitar where I
talk about various regions that get
conquered and then some chronicle
mentions a number. Okay. But it's it's
very hard. It's very sketchy that time.
I and this is this is we're now nearing
to what traditionally was called the
dark ages because we have which by the
way and we can get into is a product of
Islam. Okay. And many people don't know
this. Um and since I'm at it, okay,
we're almost there. So basically after
what happened and the discont so the
Mediterranean used to be known as kind
of the Roman lake and everyone Egypt and
Syria and all of North Africa and Europe
were all connected. It was part of one
empire. After Islam took everything
basically south of that, North Africa
and the Middle East. It come and I
already told you that was the richer,
more profound, the more sophisticated
region, little Europe, the the rest of
the Christian was cut off completely.
Papyrus ended. It used to come from
Egypt. That was that supply was
eliminated. All of that is historically
this is was the beginning of what
historians would call the dark ages.
Okay? And you don't know I mean and one
historian uh Henry Perne he was I think
a Belgian historian in the 19th century
an orientalist as they called them he
actually had an entire thesis about this
uh it was and basically his line is
without Muhammad there'd be no
Charlemagne uh the rise of Charlemagne
and the Frankish state was basically a
response to the non-stop Islamic
aggression and the separ and and the
discontinuity of uh the Mediterranean.
This is why now Europe had to develop on
its own and start a new and it was you
know it was the young kid on the block
the the barbarians who had you know
conquered and assimilated into
Christendom in the fifth century and
whatnot. Um they didn't they no longer
had the assistance of the east as they
did before. Okay. And so now they became
the small final bastion of Christendom
and they continued being attacked by
Muslims. Uh so you know to finish this
idea of the dark ages. So that's yeah so
people will tell you the dark ages
historic and they don't even want to use
that term anymore for various reasons
but they would say it was the 8th
century and the 9th century and it was
they would tell you because of Viking
attacks and you know attacks from
nomadic tribes in the east but the real
attack was Islam okay that was the main
one from the south and uh the Vikings
people don't even understand that a lot
of the Viking raids especially for
slaves okay white slaves was to feed the
Arab uh slave emporium because there was
such a demand for white slaves. So they
were selling, Vikings were selling.
Yeah. They would go to Ireland and
England and France and wherever and
conquered. And all those slaves, most of
them would be sold uh uh down through
the rivers of Russia to, you know, uh to
the caliphates, the Abbassads for
example, um the Abassad Caliphate. That
used to be a well-known thing. And we
know this as well because a lot of the
treasure troves of Viking coins that are
found in Scandinavia are Arab coins, you
know. So what commodity do Vikings have
to give? Slaves. And we also have
records for it. So you know the whole
point is uh Islam has had a profound
impact on the shaping of Europe. And
there's historians I quote one in one of
my books um something Cardini where he
basically says Islam was a midwife to
Europe. It created Europe. And the
reason Europe became Marshall and you
had the night culture and everything and
a very staunch Christian kind of
defensive posture was because of Islam.
It was surrounding it and it was and
they knew what happened. They understood
that threearters of Christendom was
destroyed and conquered and Islamized.
Um you know so it's this is we haven't
even reached the Crusades. Okay. And
look what had look what Islam had done.
And I'm here to tell you and I've
because I've looked at this and parents
write to me about school books,
textbooks, and social science books.
What I just described to you doesn't
even get any mention. You just get get
one sentence about how Islam spread
through trade in the Middle East and
they won't tell you the Middle East was
so Christian before that. They always
like to act like Europe was Christian
and everything else wasn't. No, Europe
was the the the leftover portion of
Christendom that never got conquered.
Portions of it did. Spain and the
Balkans later under the Ottomans and
we'll get into that. Uh but yeah, so
this is uh I'll stop right there. Why do
you think that they were so successful
in so quickly conquering so much? Yeah,
there's a lot of theories about that. Um
the the one which I touched on is, you
know, the Roman Empire and this the
Persians were at war way right before
the Islamic conquest, literally like a
decade or two. Um they were constantly
bleeding each other. So one theory is
that they were both so exhausted that
when this new power rose up in Arabia
they were able to just conquer them
peace meal. Um so that's one. The Muslim
theory is God's on our side and this is
proof and this is why we won. The
ancient Christian the contemporary
Christian theory they always this is how
people always thought they thought we
were sinners. And so you know God had
raised Amalok against us or or whatever
the Old Testament analogy is. she's
raised some kind of pagan people to
attack the the the believers, the
Hebrews, and punish them and chastise
them for their evil ways. So that comes
out regularly uh amongst the Christian.
Do you think that there's anything in
the culture of Christianity that Yeah.
Well, that's the Edward Gibbon argument.
Okay. Which is basically that um you
know because of Christianity, it sort of
emasculated the Marshall ethos of the
Roman Empire and it made them sitting
ducks, you know, for the Arabs. That's
also a um I don't know how accurate that
is because uh you still find very
Marshall Christians during this time you
know
like so okay so Charlemagne is now the
year 800 we have the rise of Charlemagne
wait before we get to Charlemagne though
so uh they the the the Muslim armies are
they don't conquer tours and they're
fought back right and I think all the
way back to Spain if my you correct me
if I get any of this history right yeah
no no right so so what what galvaniz
izes them the the the Europeans to fight
back and why is it that they don't go
past into at that point presumably it's
called Aland Andeloo right so that's
what the Arabs call it yeah um what what
would this Europeans have called that
region uh to them it was I mean it's
known sometimes as Iberia but it's this
the Spain because it was various Spanish
kingdoms before it became one Hispania
that was I think it's Latin term so
there was at least by the time they got
to tours which is a long way into far
into Europe. There was a a sort of
galvanizing of Christians, Christian
armies and there was a military
response, right? So in Spain you had the
Visigoths. Okay. And um Elendaloo is
actually because the Arabs they somehow
confuse the Visigoths with the Vandals.
Lendaloo. Vandals. Okay. So that's I
think the origin of the etmology of
that. Okay. Why they call it that. Yeah.
Because the Vandals were in North Africa
also a little before that time. And I
they conflate them all together.
Vandals, Visigothth. Um, they fought
back, the Visigothths, and they lost. I
mean, they were, and again, we can,
again, these are very sketchy sources.
We just have one or two chronicles that
are vague, but we know they fought back
and there were major battles. Um but
they lost and they got Islamized and but
but then um a very small um you know a
very small group of Christians according
to both Muslim and it's very it's a very
interesting story um led by a man named
Paleo or Pelagius and he was the one who
is supposedly initiated the reconista.
So they fled into the rocky barren
regions of the northwestern quadrant of
the Spanish peninsula and they lived in
caves just a small group of Christians.
Okay. And the rest of the Christians
were became vimmese or sec you know
subjects of the Islamic state paying
tribute and being essentially secondass
citizens. And um but from that small
hole in the northwest quadrant is where
the um reconist begins and it just it
comes down slowly southwards. So that's
almost immediately after. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. according to the uh
yeah and then you've got sort of 800
years of battles between them until 1492
basically and still Muslims are there
even after 1492 but so basically from
7-Eleven we're talking like over 700
years almost eight uh of and it's so you
know to me Spain is a microcosm of the
sort of Christian Muslim wars because
it's all just concentrated in one little
nation and uh it you know all the things
that we know that we can talk about
about these conflicts manifest
themselves in you know stark display in
Spain, okay? Because you have the
Christians versus the Muslims. The
Muslims are in the south, Christians are
in the north. They're in constant
warfare. So they're not actually living
amongst each other. They push to
different regions. Well, so the free
Christians of the north that were a
small group, they started pushing south
and they were independent and they were
the enemies of the Muslims. A lot of
Christians during the conquest did live
in the south with the Muslims as
secondass dimmies, subjects. Okay? And
every time is as usual when the Muslims
and the Christians were fighting the the
Muslims of the south versus the free
Christians of the north, the Muslims
would take it out on their own
Christians as a sort of collective
punishment, you know, and uh yeah, that
comes out a lot. Um so, and while we're
at it, because someone's going to say,
well, what about the great Andia, and
this is where um you know, this is where
Jews and Christians and Muslims
prospered and they loved each other.
This is one of the themes that is or
apology as that often comes up and all I
have to say to that well the the easy
answer anyone who really wants to delve
into this question they should read um
the professor he's a he's a friend of
mine Daario Fernandez Morera he wrote a
book called the endoclesian myth a whole
book okay just tearing into this idea um
but just to give you one example at the
height of this golden age you have
what's called the the martyrs of Cordoba
which is something like 50 60 Christians
who get boiled, skinned alive, impaled,
beheaded because they blasphemed against
Muhammad. Okay, so this is like, you
know, they finally they they found what
they want to claim is this great time of
tolerance and beauty and yeah, but
they're acting like ISIS on steroids.
Okay, but we don't talk about that. So
my point is just to show you that even
when they try to find something, it's if
you really look into it, no, it's the
same as usual. What they're really
boasting about is it was so wealthy. So
Andalucia was wealthy and people will
talk about oh look at the backwards
Europe they were you know whatever poor
and look at this grand civilization and
what they don't tell you is most of that
wealth was because the Muslims were
plundering it from the Europeans
including selling them on the slave
market and plundering them essentially
and that's usually that has always
traditionally been Islam's capital other
people's stuff. Were they converting
Europeans to Islam? Um yeah so when they
conquered Spain for example I'm sure a
lot of mo uh native Spaniards Christians
converted. Okay. And was it did did they
bring sort of civiliani civilization
with them from so that's the question.
Was it a was it a sort of military
nation of of a kind of band of warrior
aristocracy. Yeah warrior. Yeah that's
you that's definitely how it was
originally initially. And um so when you
look sometimes they'll tell you well
yeah but you know the middle the Islamic
world was so advanced when Europe was in
the dark ages. Okay. So what they don't
tell you is one it this is still an
early time. So that a lot of the people
who you know were inventing things or
doing something you know avarose the
philosopher or whatever. A lot of these
guys were either Christians or Jews or
or even more often they were just they
had recently converted. So the you know
he I this important person or whatever
just became a Muslim recently or he was
the son of a man who converted. So a lot
of times you know whatever credit is
being allotted to Islam was really by
Jews and Christians of the old
civilizations doing what they've always
been doing. Okay but sort of Islam gets
the credit but where where Islam really
takes over and then it you know really
spreads and everyone becomes Muslim you
see the opposite. Okay. um in Spain to
go back to that it was the they were the
Muslims were obligated especially when
the Christians of the north were still
weak to wage two jihads every year and
it was always devastating and they came
back with the heads of you know they
would decapitate make they were
obligated to by who by Islamic law the
khalif said twice a year and there are
Islamic teachings in in the Sharia of
you have to when you can you have to
launch raids on the infidel you can't
live in peace with them as long as you
can obviously if you're weak you
shouldn't. Um so and very graphic to the
point that until now there are portions
of Spain especially the middle zone
where the frontier that are completely
destroyed and they still can't bring it
back to life. It's just a complete war
zone from all that. Okay. Wow. Yeah. So
um so that's that's the Anyway, it's
good we can kind of stop right here real
quick because now we're getting to near
the crusade time and we haven't even
gotten there. But just think it for a
while like all this is what happened
before the first crusade, right? Yeah.
And when we talk about the first
crusade, you're going to find out the
problem is people presented in a vacuum.
They don't tell you what I just told
you. And all of a sudden it's just these
crazy Catholics decided to go and like
go abuse the poor. A guy like John
Espazito, I don't know if you've heard
of him, he's a professor from Georgetown
where I went and there's a quote which I
quote so often that I think I've
memorized it from him. And he says five
centuries of peaceful coexistence
elapsed between Muslims and Christians
until an imperial imperial papal power
play led to series of so-called holy
wars which have left an enduring legacy
of mistrust and resentment amongst
Muslims. In other words, before the
first crusade which was called in 1095.
I haven't even gotten there. I've
basically stopped around 800. Right.
Yeah. Before that he's saying Muslims
and Christians lived in perfect peace
and harmony. Even though I just got done
telling you that Muslims conquered
threequarters of the Islamic war world
of Christian world through sheer
violence and bloodshed. Okay? And that's
what he and and the thing is it's not
just him. This is the official line
amongst historians and academics and he
I mentioned him because he was at he was
especially back in the day when I was
going there he every military analysts
and politicians would consult him about
questions about Islam. And it's the same
thing with people like Karen Armstrong.
you know, she's a best-selling author
about religions. You read what she says
again, she'll all she'll start off with
the Crusades and just how evil it was
and act like everything before it was
nothing but Muslims being good to
Christians. Okay. So, one, so these are
what we would call, you know, omiss um
you know, omission. Yeah. Um so, so but
at that point though, do we need to go
back to Charlemagne to tie the bow on
Charlemagne? No. No, not really. I mean,
you know, he he's great for his own
thing. Charles the Great. I'll give you
one quick anecdote again because it
shows you the games they play. So, uh,
it's known that he and Haron al-
Rasheed, the Khalif, the Abbassad Khalif
had good relations. Okay. And people use
this often as O see. And where was that
Khalif based? Uh, Baghdad. Okay. Yeah.
Um, the Abbassad caliphate. And then
we're talking now, you know, the year
800 or a little after. And people will
always show you. Yeah. See, it's, you
know, Islam and Christians got along.
telling you I got two you got two
emperors or a khalif and an emperor and
they were friends etc etc and they gave
gifts to one each other but when you dig
in and you read the chronicles and I
quoted I'm pretty sure in sword and
simaria I I discuss um his the
chronicler of Charlemagne he makes it
perfectly clear that the reason
Charlemagne was being nice and reaching
out to Haron Rasheed was to was in
almost like he was bribing him to be
good to the Christians under his
authority in Egypt in Iraq in in the
Islamic world because there were so any
Christians. So he says that the
chronicler he says the reason he sought
out friendships was so he can make the
plight of Christians living in those
regions less and he can help them. Okay.
So you see how again that is omitted but
we're told about oh look they got along
because Muslims and Christians always
get along. So that's I can leave it at
that with Charlemagne. So uh then let's
go to the Crusades. Yeah. This is quite
a a whistleblow Torah but yeah. Um so
it's 1095. So 1095 but we have to start
a little earlier to give context. So you
know everything I discussed was during
the Arab the rise of the Arab empire and
it went through iterations. You had the
Omiads and then you had the Abbasids
which I just mentioned. Um and then
sometime after that you know the the the
the Abbassads start importing Turkish
slaves and Islamizing them. Slave
soldiers okay like the Janiseries and
the Mamluks. Um, and but you know, long
story short, before long, you know, the
Turks become very Muslim and they become
Sunni Muslims. Um, which is important
because we're going to talk a little bit
about Shia. And, um, eventually they
take over and they still keep the
caliphate, the Abbassid, but he's more
of a puppet figure. And the real power
is the Seljic Sultan. All right. Now,
during this time, especially from like
1050 to 1090, okay? Right before the
first crusade, these Seljixs are running
a muk. Okay? So the persecution and the
destruction of Christians that I had
mentioned earlier under the Arabs times
10. I mean now it's just it's horrific.
Okay. They start in Armenia, greater
Armenia, which is, you know, far what we
would say eastern Anatolia. And
according to the records, you know, I'm
thinking of Matthew Adessa who was a
contemporary. They were just killing
tens of thousands of Christians,
Armenians, Greeks, okay, and burning
every church in Ani, which was the
capital at the time of Armenia. It was
known as the city of a thousand1
churches. They ritually burned down
every church, destroyed every crucifix.
I tell you that to also underscore
because a lot of people will tell you,
okay, the Turks, you know, it's people
were waring. It's different tribes and
they try to um, you know, minimize the
religious element. So that's why I'm
telling you that in their own sources,
it it's very clear that they did what
ISIS would do. They symbolically were
trying to denigrate Christianity. They
would destroy churches. They would take
the greatest cross of the greatest
church and send it as a war trophy to
Baghdad to the Khalif. Okay, so my point
is it wasn't just warfare. It was it had
that jihadist ideological component.
Okay, which again historians like to
just ignore as some sort of you know
whatever, but it's in the sources. And
um they were also in the Holy Land. You
know, you had pilgrims that were always
going to the Holy Land even though it
was a hard venture and they would get
persecuted even before that under the
Arabs in the seventh, 8th, 9th
centuries. Now the Turks really took a
new level and you know they would attack
the pilgrims. They would extort even
more money than they had to pay. There's
one instant incident that happened in
1065 which really was a scandal. They
attacked a large German pilgrimage and
they gang rape the nun and you know made
everyone watch it like like really
horrific stuff. They would go in
churches and disembowel people and just
smear the blood on the altar again as a
form of mockery. Okay. So this is this
is what's building up towards the first
crusade. And then um it really gets bad
after the battle of Manzikert, which is
one of my main battles also in in my
book Sword and Scimitar. And the
Christians again lose. Where is that
battle? It's in Manzakert, which is
actually close to Armenia in Asia Minor.
Um the Roman Emperor at the time went
trying again like Yarmmuk, they went
with a large army trying to stop these
the Seljuk Turks and they lost. And
after that they just completely ran a
muck all westward and now they're
attacking all Asia Minor of course I
mean Turkey what we call now it's Turkey
because it got conquered during this
time. Um and Asia Minor by the way you
know so Turkey when you hear Turkey you
think okay it's a Muslim nation this is
this was such a Christian nation that
you know St. Paul's letters, most of
them go there, Asia Minor, Turkey. Yeah,
a lot of them. And uh so now it's all
conquered and now they're right next to
Constantinople and they're on the verge
of actually reaching and getting into
the European mainland. And the emperor,
the Roman emperor at the time, Alexis,
he calls for aid from the Franks and
the, you know, the Europe. And he had
friends there and, you know, some nobles
and they all got together. And then long
story short, Pope Pope Urban II at the
Council of Claremont in 1095 in
November, he basically stood up and he
told everything that was happening. He
mentioned everything I'm telling you.
All the desecrations of churches, all
the rape of women and the sl and the
forced Islamization of children and the
disembowing of Christians. Very graphic
stuff. Okay. And which is in a lot of
sources. So it's not, you know, one guy
made it up. Um, and that's it. And they
all cried out Deos Vult, which Mr. Hex
Seth has a a tattoo, which means God
wills it, right? And that was it. They
they they they went so if you ask
earlier historians, you know, in the
1800s, they would tell you the crusades
were motivated by love. You know, they
were actually in a lot of the it comes
out in some of the sources where the
crusaders were moved by Christ's
injunction to love your fellow man as
much as yourself and to love God. So
they were loving God because they wanted
to go and liberate the holy sele. They
wanted to liberate the holy land which
was very important. Yeah. Again, this is
something modern people don't
understand, but um place was important.
You know, holy sacred land was something
that was, you know, very important. So,
they wanted to go and liberate it from
Muslim control. And they wanted to also
protect fellow Christians. And now, you
know, your average person, you hear the
word crusade, it's such a diabolical
evil thing, evil venture. But that marks
an interesting turning point even from
the Christian point of view from this
let's say turn the other cheek mentality
to we're going to protect our fellow
Christians by killing others. Yeah. So
the the whole issue you know this goes
back to the concept of just war which
really one of the name that always gets
thrown out there and it's it's chief
articulator they would say and proponent
is Augustine St. Augustine who lived in
the fourth century. Okay. Um or it was
it fifth century. So he's way before all
this and to him and to almost every
other doctor of the church and
theologian it was okay to fight back and
you know they would cite things like um
you know Roman centurion comes to Jesus
and uh Jesus heals his servant and then
Jesus you know what does Jesus do when
he does a miracle for someone he tells
him to repent right change your way he
didn't tell this guy hey put your sword
away stop killing I mean this guy was a
centurion he saw he oversaw the
bloodshed, a lot of bloodshed. Jesus
didn't say anything to him. Okay. So,
also John the Baptist, you know, when
people came to him and a bunch of
soldiers came to him and saying, "What
must we do?" He didn't tell them, "Leave
the army." He said, "Don't be content
with your pay." Okay? So, a lot of these
were understood by early church
theologians as justifying just war
theory. As long as the war is not about,
you know, conquest and enforcing
whatever my will on you, if I'm
defending my land, that was 100%
Christian. Okay? And so, and this is
why, okay, so if you don't understand
everything everything I've been saying,
if you didn't hear this, then how is
crusades just war? Because what you see
is a bunch of Europeans going to Muslim
territory. What's just in that? But if
you know the truth, which is, well, that
was Christian territory and they were
killing Christians still and destroying
Christian lands and holy sacred places,
then it did become part of the just war
theory. You see what I'm saying? But
it's 300 years since that it had been
Muslim. Yeah. Yeah. But I mean, to their
thinking, that point of view and it was
still full of Christians and you know I
mean I don't think they they went by
what's it like statues of limitations
right they didn't think that way you
know so okay so in their mind I still
rationalized it but but specifically it
was because they were killing Christians
and attacking Christians places okay so
that was it yeah even if it wasn't
Christian beforehand I think they would
have just war theory would cover the
logic why are you killing innocent
Christians so this is what the first of
several crusades Yeah. Can you take me I
actually am not too good on crusade
history. Can you take me through to
through them? Sure. Um so the first
crusade is 10. The first crusade is the
most successful one. It's arguably the
only successful one because they got
what they want. They went through they
and the sufferings they went through are
amazing. But they liberated various
Christian regions and cities Antioch
Adessa and most importantly Jerusalem
because that's what they really wanted.
the holy sele or the church of the
resurrection was this massive complex
that was built um at top what is
believed to have been Jesus's um burial
where not just his burial it was
actually a humongous structure built
during Constantine's time in the 300s
that this so in this church you actually
had where Jesus uh um was betrayed the
garden of Gethsemane and then you also
had where he was crucified and you have
where he was buried okay and it was a it
was and resurrected uh and quick
anecdote which I almost forgot but is
pivotal to what we're talking about in
the year 1009. Okay, we got to go back
in time a little bit and just again what
I'm going to tell you is going to again
underscore just how Christian that
region was and underscore the sorts of
persecution that went. But there was a
fatimid khalif in Egypt and the fatimid
was okay and his name
is and this guy okay they call him the
mad khalif because they want to they
want to pretend that what he did what
I'm going to tell you was the product of
a maniac right there's no rationale
under him he had 30,000 churches in
Egypt and in greater Syria destroyed
okay so first of all 30,000 that's a
humongous number of churches in an area
that I thought was Muslim okay uh Um,
and the source for this, which a lot of
Western people try to ignore, is an
Arabic Muslim source, Al-Makrizi. All
right? And he says 30,000. And people
say, "No, no, that's a mistake. You put
one more, one, two, one, too many
zeros." You know, he meant 300. And
historians will write, "Oh, 300
churches." But he wrote 30,000,
including the holy sele, the one that
I'm discussing. He had it destroyed and
pulverized. And then it was later
rebuilt, a smaller version. But the one
that was that I was telling you about by
Constantine, he had it raised to the
ground. this most important place um for
Christianity. As far as my geography of
Jerusalem goes, that must have been huge
because where I know the the the rock
where the crucifix was the distance to
that where it is believed to you're
talking about the rock with the round
stone that there's two places that
people believe where Christ was um uh
buried. The the one you're talking about
I think is the later one. Mostly
Protestants actually except Catholics
and and Orthodox believe it was
somewhere which was actually closer.
Okay. Yeah. Okay. Where the the
crusades, the first one is the most
successful, right? And then the how did
the first crusades end? Yeah. Let me
just finish the Fatima thing because
this is very important because it ties
up to what we're talking about. So
30,000 churches destroyed. And again, I
want to remind you, you have these
people who are telling us five centuries
of peaceful coexistence were between
Muslims and Christians. What I just told
you is 109. This is the time frame
they're talking about. 30,000 churches
were completely destroyed. Okay? And
these people are writing books and
saying everything was fine until the
first crusade. You see how they present
things in a vacuum. Yeah. They don't
want you to they want you to think that
the Christians were the aggressors. They
had no reason to do what they did. Okay.
All right. So then okay the crusades you
have various what gives rise to them is
essentially then the Muslims start
winning back and conquering. So around
11:44 you have the second crusade
because some Muslim sultan destroys
Adessa on Christmas day which was a
Christian principality and uh it was
full of Armenians and Greeks and again
to give you idea in the sources when the
Franks and the crusaders came and
liberated these regions which had a lot
of indigenous Christians, Armenians and
Greeks and Syriaks, the sources talk
about how they threw themselves and
kissed their hands and feet. Now why
would they do that? I thought I thought
they lived in harmony with their Muslim
overlords. Why would they want these
strange men from Europe? Because they
were all Christians, okay? And they were
being persecuted. Um, so in 10 1144, the
Adessa is completely ransacked and
destroyed and just again like very
sadistic stuff is happening to the women
and children and it gave rise to a new
crusade. Okay. And that one was abysmal
failure. They got nothing. They just
died. everyone who came it was under
King Louie and Conrad I believe the
German emperor completely destroyed and
then you know things kind of status quo
and you still have Jerusalem you still
have Antioch and other places and then
you get the rise of Saladin okay and
he's very as we all know very popular
and uh uh you know he he actually um
conquers Jerusalem all right he the the
a major battle the battle of Hatin the
two horns which is my in my bug sword
and scimitar has a whole chapter
In 1187 he wins and he beats a massive
crusader army of the kingdom of
Jerusalem. And after that they all fall
like dominoes. He conquers Jerusalem. He
conquers a lot of Christian territories
and there's only a few left. And that's
what calls the third crusade. King
Richard is of course the one who
spearshead it but also King Philip as as
well from France. Um and Barbar Roa the
German emperor who unfortunately brought
the biggest army but then died on his
way. He fell in the river. He was very
old. Um but you know and very and king
and Richard is very impressive. I have a
whole chapter dedicated to him and the
third crusade in defenders of the west
because he's when you read about this
guy and the actual sources it's amazing.
Apparently he was a giant. Okay.
Something like 66 or you know because
really yeah at at that time and and the
sources just describe him always leading
his men being the center of the charge
the first one in decapitating
slaughtering everyone. And the Muslims
themselves actually in their sources
talk about him like that. So he was
quite the formidable character. Uh very
interesting. Anyway, the third crusade
was kind of uh not a total victory but
not a total loss. Like him and Saladin
made a treaty so Christians can go back
to Jerusalem but it was still under
Islamic control and and and you know
whatever. And um then you have the
fourth crusade which is basic which
people love to point fingers at because
it's where the crusaders go and sack
Constantinople right Christians
attacking Christians and that has its
own story and different versions of why
that happened. Um but before we get into
that I'm just remembering again very
important point about Saladin before we
leave Saladin. Um now this guy have you
you've heard how magnanimous Saladin was
right and for because I follow this and
I read a lot of books. okay about this.
He's always held up as this great
magnanimous and very tolerant uh you
know sultan until today people say
Christians can learn from him and his
magnanimity etc etc and he's to me and I
made a video about him you know he's the
epitome of fake history because why do
people say that so okay if you look in
the sources especially the so they
here's what they'll tell you when
Saladan conquered Jerusalem which he did
uh in 1187 he allowed the Christians to
leave peacefully and he is very
magnanimous and they always contrast it
with the first crusade uh in 1099 when
the Christians conquered Jerusalem
apparently there was a blood bath okay
they killed everyone in sight okay so
they use this now what they don't tell
you okay is one according to the Muslim
sources he was like a fanatic jihadist
who did nothing but like but persecute
anyone who went against Islamic law in
Egypt he had the Christians the cops
persecuted he had their churches tarred
for what did they too, right? Um they're
not crusaders. And then uh he had after
the battle of Hatton, a group, the
group, the knights of the temple in the
hospital, he gave them the choice of
convert to Islam or be beheaded. They
all said no. And he had something like
300 of them decapitated. In fact, going
back to how ISIS, you know, likes to
live off history. When you see ISIS, the
Islamic State, and those videos they
made of cop to Christians or whoever,
and they have them in the orange
jumpsuit and they push them over and
carve their heads off, that is directly
lifted from what Saladin had done to
these Christians at the battle of Han.
Exactly. That's how it's described and
they're emulating it. Okay. And uh you
know, ALS he did all sorts of other
nasty stuff. His his dying wish was to
not just get rid of the crusaders in the
Holy Land, but to invade Europe until no
one lived who didn't believe in Allah. I
mean, this doesn't sound like a
magnanimous tolerant guy to me. You know
what I mean? Okay. Um, and then in even
what he did in in um in Jerusalem, this
supposedly magnanimous gesture, he no
blood bath, if you look at the sources,
what really happened is they told him he
was besieging and he said, "Okay, they
and he and they tried to surrender and
he said, "No, I'm going to kill every
last one of you." But then they said,
"Okay, we're going to destroy Ala Mosque
because they had possession of we're
going to destroy all the holy sites of
is of Islam and we're going to kill all
our all hostages." So he finally agreed
to let them go if they can pay a ransom.
Okay? And the ones who couldn't, which
was something like 8,000 or or 16,000, I
have the number written down. And mostly
women and children because they were
poor were in consigned to slavery. Okay?
So it's like but he's being used today
as this paragon of virtue and
magnanimity. Okay. And people believe
that. And where does it come from? It
actually comes from Sir Walter Scott's
novels. Okay. Yeah. He created this
chivalous kind of Saladin and all that's
what people believe as if it's real
history. Okay. So anyway, I just wanted
to emphasize that because uh you know
Saladin is a very popular figure when we
talk about the Crusades and so much of
what is said about him is just you know
overdone just so you can so they can put
up a Muslim on a pedestal and try to
shame Christians with but when you look
at the reality it's just not there. And
where did the Jews fit in all of this?
Were they they I understood that many of
them were killed. Yeah. Yeah. So the the
Jews, you know, even before I mean, and
here's again one of those things where
people try to demonize the crusades
because they attacked and killed Jews
and they did. Um but you know, the Jews
were being attacked and killed by
Christians even before that. But what
happened is um you know a lot of it was
mostly the peasant crusaders not the
actual knights and uh you know the
formal armies but a lot of them would go
and you know they'd get riled up and say
why are we traveling all this distance
during their long trek to kill infidels
who hate Jesus when we have them right
here the Jews who killed him and they
would rile themselves up and they'd go
attack and kill them. There were some
terrible pilgrims weren't there. Yeah.
Yeah. But you know, it's also important
to know that the church and the leaders
were against it and against the
pilgrims. Yeah. And they and they would
issue edicts saying you have to leave
the Jews alone and they would come in
their defense. So it was almost it was
almost like what always happens. You
have the rabbel, you know, but the
actual church policy was not to
persecute them and the crusader policy
was not to persecute them or or do any
of that. But of course, you're going to
have the bad apples who act on whatever
impulse they want to just plunder them
on whatever pretext. So at this point
though, we still have the Muslims in
Spain, right? The Crusades have the the
rest of Europe then is Christian, right?
And uh the the the area that is now
Israel, Lebanon, that's kind of going
back and forth. No, that's under Muslim.
The Holy Land. Yeah. At this point now,
it's under Muslim control. The So the
Crusaders finally get expelled in 1292.
Okay. That's the end of it. Uh after the
fall of Aker or Akre, however you want
to pronounce it. That was the final
stronghold after Saladan and then the
Mluks came and and and they started
conquering more and then by 1292 you
have no more crusader presence in the
Holy Land. Okay. So, uh we'll come back
to what happens next because there's
some important events particularly
there's two sieges on Vienna by the
Ottomans and I I I'm keen to ask you
about Constantinople as well or as we
know it now Istanbul. Um, but you've
mentioned a few times as you're
discussing this that historians like to
ignore this. Historians like to ignore
that or they paint this one-sided
picture and the way you actually
describe it is that the one-sided
picture they paint is the opposite of
what is true. I'm curious about what you
think the motivation is by those
historians. I think there's several. I
think today it's just it's it's kind of,
you know, it's snowballed and it's just
that's the narrative. So if you're just
a moderately ed if you go to college
today and you're a history major and
you're studying this field you're not
going to read primary sources which you
should that used to be the original
thing. You're supposed to but go read
this you know three four books by the
secondary secondary his uh source would
be you know like me okay a modern person
who supposedly consults the primary
sources and then you know puts it into a
book form and you read it. So most
people will read that and those books
now you know they and they've been going
and and the question is why but have
painted a completely different picture
you know a guy like Sir Steven Runsman
for example who's the he wrote like four
or five volumes of the crusades and it
was considered you know the best seller
etc etc I think came out maybe in the
50s or
60s and now historians will tell you
yeah this guy really had an axe to grind
you know and he was just dedicated to
making the Christians look bad and
making the Muslims look Good. All right.
And how do we know this? Because the
ones who have taken the time to consult
the primary sources are realizing what
he's saying is not there. And often
times the opposite is there. So why?
Okay. The reason why um I would argue
today it's because of what we would call
political correctness. It's this desire
honestly, okay, really to bring it down
where you know the narrative has to
always be this Christians, whites are
bad, non-Christians, brown people are
good. Okay, this is it. That's the
mantra. and everything has to conform to
this. Why? Okay, we can get into that.
But that has been the case for, I would
say, a long time since the 60s. Okay.
Um, and the sort of self-hatred thing
has
arose. But, you know, there's also other
reasons, you know, academic reasons. For
example, you want to be a historian,
okay? The the thing that would make you
popular is you come up with a new
interpretation. So, for the longest
time, the interpretation was what I'm
telling you. But if I can come up with
something clever like, oh wait, actually
And Lucio is a great beacon of light and
learning. Okay, wow. Then I've made a
new contribution, especially if it's
what people want to hear. People want to
hear that narrative for the reasons I
just explained. They don't want to hear
about, okay, Christians and Muslims
fighting because Muslims are aggressors,
etc. M so all of these um but you know
again today in the current climate it's
just you know what I'm saying right now
I don't care how my books sword and
scimitar has like over a thousand
citations endnotes to show you where I
got my stuff because I already knew I'm
going to be attacked where'd you get
that where'd you get that so the facts
are there but you know people just they
still till this very day want to believe
that narrative okay which and you see it
everywhere manifestations of what I just
said this narrative even if you're
watching the news and there's some kind
of incident or criminal activity between
a black man and a white man or
something. It has to be spun a certain
way. So of course it's been going on
with history because you know history
people talk about fake news and it's
very important obviously but to me fake
history is more important because fake
news is ephemeral and it you know
creates its mischief but then it you
know vanishes and we move on something
else. Fake history you create
overarching narratives and and um you
know basically paradigms where you sift
reality through. So if I've created a
fake history where you know Muslim
Christian relations are such that
Christians were the evil aggressors and
Muslims were the poor guys. Well of
course now when you talk about anything
in the modern era and you see it through
that lens it all makes perfect sense and
gives you more reason to despise the
Christians and the westerners etc. And
that's what's been going on for a long
time. Which is why I think when I
discuss these things, you know, the
number one response I get from people is
like, I'm embarrassed. I didn't know
this. You know, why didn't I learn this
in school? And well, I'm this is why you
don't know. You didn't because there's a
narrative. Fake news has a political
agenda than fake history. It's the
agenda. It's more profound, but it's
still somewhat political, right? Yeah.
Of course, it is political and it it
manifests itself ultimately in a
political way, but it's very subtle and
it's harder to prove. And you know, so
fake news, we can argue, oh, here's
evidence that this guy didn't say
whatever. But fake history, you know,
who's going to take the time to delve
into the primary sources like, let's say
I did, and I did it cuz I love it and I
was at the Library of Congress and I had
access to all those books and I know a
couple of languages, you know, so it's
not that easy to do that. and you're
just going to go by if I go to the
bookstores, Barnes & Nobles for example,
um, and I go to the Middle East or a
history section, all the books, and I'm
familiar with them, they're all the
politically correct books that say the
exact opposite of what I'm telling you.
Yeah. So, if you mean well and you want
to read a book and you educate yourself
and you go to Barnes & Nobles, you're
just going to you're going to you're
going to you're going to learn the exact
opposite. And that's why I always find
it funny that you're better off being
ignorant. Because if you're ignorant, if
you're an un unlearned, learned person,
maybe just dropped, you know, high
school and you didn't go to college,
you're probably going to have a better
understanding of what we're talking
about from an instinctual level at
least. Yeah. But if you go the further
you go to higher education and formally
study these things, what happens is the
le you learn the exact opposite, but
then you're proud of it and you're so
visalous about what you know because I
got a degree. I know what I know this.
You don't know what you're talking
about. But what happened is you've been
indoctrinated in lies. Yeah. So look,
you've mentioned a couple of books that
have changed the popular understanding
of let's say the Crusades and these very
various other moments. But would you
could you pinpoint to a specific moment
in time when the narrative changed from
as you described earlier there was a
common understanding in Europe about
Islam aggression in Europe to now where
most have no idea. Is there a moment in
time where that the transitional phase?
Yeah. Which is a good good question. So,
okay. Honestly, it all really starts
with and and a lot of people don't like
to hear this, but with the Protestant
Reformation, okay, because with the
break with the Catholic Church was a
need to, you know, I don't want to use
the word demonized, but whatever, you
know, justify the break. And so,
anything the Catholic Church did became
jaundest and kind of bad, including the
crusades. And, you know, the Protestants
made good points, you know, indulgences,
etc., etc. I get that. That makes sense.
But you you got this move now where like
whatever we can, you know, however we
can make Catholics look bad, we should.
And that was the beginning. So Martin
Luther, he condemned the crusades. And
then he condemned when the Turks were
actually invading Vienna or coming
towards Austria, he actually said,
"Don't fight back." and and he said this
is God's way of punishing the Catholics
and church until they got close to where
he was and he actually changed his tomb
literally and wrote a new saying no you
can fight back it is just war this is
I'm not lying to you this is true I can
give you the evidence how's that for
motivated reasoning yeah so so it really
starts with a pro and look I'm not
people I'm not I don't want to get into
the I'm not a theologian I'm not arguing
who's right theologically I'm just
saying as a historical development the
rift between in Christendom between
Protestants and Catholics created a sort
of hatred towards the crusades, okay?
Because it was another thing to point at
and say, "Oh, look." And then and they
also this is was also the the beginning
of the rehabilitation of of Muslims in
the eyes of Europeans because if Muslims
are the enemies of the bad guys, the
Catholics, they must be good. Okay? And
this is why till today it's actually
Protestant nations that are suffering
from Islam because they're the ones who
have completely opened their doors and
who who follow this logic which is
Muslims are great. It's the Catholics
you got to worry about. Okay. Or or at
least elements of it still
subconsciously maybe exist. Um and
that's why you have Muslims running a
muck in Scandinavia and Sweden, in the
UK and in Germany. Um then but then you
look at countries like uh you know
Hungary and Poland which is you know
Hungary I know is Catholic and co and so
is Poland and you don't see that sort of
thing as much of course and I think
that's a u so anyway that's the
beginning of it. I would say the
Protestant Reformation and again this
isn't me I'm not talking about theology.
I'm talking about historical development
which is normal of course. Um and then
you get the enlightenment, right? And
with the enlightenment all of a sudden
now now there's a kind of it's not that
the Muslims are good but yeah these
Christians are fanatics. This is now
Edward Gibbon for example um is and
Voltater and these guys it so now once
again the the crusaders and their calls
looks ridiculous and they're stupid and
what what are they fighting over this is
dumb etc. Okay. And then you move on
until you come to sort of the modern you
know 19th century 1800s. Now you have
serious scholars, orientalists, and um
you know, they just approach it in a
very cold fashion that are I I actually
like their writings. They're objective,
okay? And they're looking at the sources
and um they're actually better than the
other guys, but you still have the
influence of the sort of, you know, the
Protestant disdain for crusades and you
have the, you know, the Enlightenment
disdain as well. Um and then you come
into the modern era where again I think
it's this need, you know, we comes from,
you know, I want to
I think sometime in the 60s you get this
move, this very anti-Christian thing
where you know Christians and Europeans
and Westerners are the root of all
problems. Okay. And of course this is
how the crusades been. So now it's being
taught that way and you know we're
gravitating back. So now it's worse than
ever because what they're doing is
they're lit literally playing with
history. I already gave you an example
of all the horrors that happened before
the first crusade. In one year 30,000
churches were destroyed. This is say
nothing of the killings of Christians
under Hakim Amra the Fatimid Khif or all
the other ones and they ignore all that
intentionally and just tell you crusades
just happened out of the blue five
centuries of peace down the toilet and
now and now Muslims can you imagine that
when 9/11 and all that happened and and
until now when there's an Islamic terror
attack in Europe they try to actually
associate it to the crusades and say
well Muslims are still upset about that
they have grievances is okay. And they
don't I mean because Muslims are not
idiots. They actually respect the
crusades in the sense that oh okay there
was a time when Christians fought back.
Oh okay good for them right but but I
mean everything is being done you know
to just rewire everything so it fits
that narrative. So let's go back to the
the history of it
at both sides of Europe at the sort of
midsecond millennia. We have the
Inquisition happening in in Spain and we
have the Ottomans charging well not only
Constantinople but right up as far as uh
Vienna. Maybe we start with the
Inquisition. Sure. So and here I'm going
to talk about the Inquisition but you're
going to you're going to start finding
something interesting here is like any
all these major historical epics and and
um you know developments that we talk
about you're going to find Islam snuck
in somehow including in the in
Inquisition. Okay, so the Inquisition to
us is, you know, oh, just crazy
fanatical Christians torturing everyone
to get the facts, etc. And then there's
elements of that as well. Okay, but it
really started, why did it start in
Spain? Because it was part of the war
with Islam. And after the the reconista
now is finally coming to an end and all
the Muslims have been beaten far south
that they're all now in Granada,
southern tip of Spain, right? And this
is under Ferdinand and Isabella, right?
Um the unification of Spain as well. So
now they're all holed up, but they're
about half a million Muslims. Okay?
And initially the Christians allowed
them to keep their religion and keep
their Sharia and live. But whenever they
could, the Muslims would basically try
to subvert and attack, including with
Barbary pirates and with the Ottomans.
They were like a fifth column and they
would attack Christians whenever they
could and kill them, etc. So it came
down to you either become a Christian or
you leave. go back to North Africa where
your ancestors came from and so now the
why become a Christian right now today
it's seen as oh look at these intolerant
crazy Catholics they just force the
religion on everyone no the logic was if
they become Christians this jihadist
animist they have for us will have to go
away because now they're like us okay
that that was the only logic okay become
like us and lose your hatred for us or
leave so a fatwa came out a feta was a a
decree by a very well by several
respected Islam IC jurists from North
Africa who employ who invoked the
doctrine of tea. Okay. And tea is basa
means you can dissemble your true
beliefs about Islam. You can say you're
a Christian but as long as you're truly
a Muslim in your heart and you're doing
this as a strategim you can do it as but
continue to hate the infidel and
whatever continue trying to plot against
them. So a fatwa came out and all half
million Muslims overnight became
Christians and they converted and were
baptized and and long story short they
this the sources described them as being
better Christians than the Christians.
They were punctual to church and
everything but they were home reading
the Quran to their children and
preaching undying hatred for Christian
Spain and still trying to plot. Okay.
And that was the beginning of the
Inquisition. Okay. Because they the
Christians didn't know what to do. They
didn't want to get rid of them because
they converted and what if he is a
sincere Christian and what if he's not?
But they were but they weren't aware
that they were being deceitful. Yeah.
Finally, when they finally learned that
they were being deceived, there's one
guy who I quote, I think he's a priest
from 15th century. And he says these
these people were better Christians than
us. And yet in their hearts they still
believed and were following the
impostor, you know, prophet. Okay. And
uh so they were still a fifth column but
an even more dangerous one. And the
Muslim sources say and a lot of the
people very early cryptic references a
lot of the men who were women I I
suppose who were engaged in tea were
burned because of the inquisition. So
that is really the and and there's
elements of this with Jews as well. I
think they're called, you know, one
one's the Morisos were the Moors who
supposedly converted but were still kind
of practicing their Islam and the
Moranos I believe were the Jews who for
the and when people talk about the
Inquisition, my point is they always
mention the Jews, but it was actually a
lot more Muslims who were being tried
for that very reason. And uh you know,
Catholic Spain just ended up basically
saying you're either one of us or you
have to go be- because you're plotting
against us obviously and the only way we
can determine it is through an
Inquisition. I'm not trying to justify
the Inquisition. I'm just trying to show
you once again how Islam is in the
background, how it provoked a pretty bad
reaction. But you you have called some
of the behavior of Islam and and the
Muslims as they as they grew out from
the Arabian Peninsula up into Europe as
brutal and barbaric. Would you describe
the Inquisition in such ways? Sure. I
mean the Inquisition there I'm sure
there are innocent people who suffered
and the Inquisition uh was involved with
the Knights of the Temple for example
and that's a topic I've actually delved
in very recently for my recent book
where these guys who had vowed and done
everything to fight for Christendom were
actually tortured by fellow Christians
on on you know baseless charges that
were made by the king who wanted their
you know gold. So I'm sure a lot of
people were I'm not justifying the
Inquisition. I'm just I'm more
interested in trying to show you how
once again Islam gave rise to something
that was very negative in Europe. You
know the rec or even you know the okay
the Christopher Columbus he sailed the
you know the ocean blue because he's
looking for spices. People again don't
understand the whole thing was about
Islam. Okay. Yeah I know that's because
that's but he couldn't go east anymore.
You couldn't go east because if you go
east you get killed okay by the Muslims
the Ottomans and the Mlukes and so
forth. And not only that, in his own
writings, he was doing this partially to
help with the crusade. He wanted to find
people who he thought would be
Christians or converted to Christianity
and then they can be mobilized to go
like an apinser movement around and
attack the Islamic world and liberate
Jerusalem. So it was still that or even
the Portuguese before him, you know, um
the Portuguese explorers who are usually
Prince Henry I think is uh or Henrik II
is the main one who's attributed with
this sort of traveling around the world.
He was a complete crusader. That was his
motivation entirely. Really? Entirely.
Oh, that was it. Wow. Um, so you see how
Islam is just embedded in in Europe's
history and so so many, you know, it's
been completely taken out. Yeah. Events
were a reaction to it. Wow. Um, so what
about then the rise of the Ottomans?
What year is uh Constant? Remind me what
year Constantinople is is 1453. May 29
when it's conquered. Yeah. Yeah. And so
what happened that was that a very
bloody uh brutal like the rest of it or
what what's the story of the of the
sacking of Constantin? Okay. So okay so
I mentioned the Seljic Turks who were
you know Turks and they were the ones
who were mainly during the first crusade
and a little bit afterwards. Um and then
the Ottomans were more Turks uh and the
names Ottoman and Seljuk. These are the
names of the founders. So Ottomans were
their founder the their forefather Osman
is his name and the other guy was Seljuk
but they're all Turks. Um and they they
rose in that area very close to
Constantinople and they eventually took
over and consolidated all the Turkish
tribes under them and the Seljixs were
gone and they became the chief power at
the time. There were really two powers
the Ottomans in Turkey and in Egypt you
had the Mluks who were slave soldiers
and Egypt kept importing them and then
eventually they took over. Um anyways
and they were contending rivals the
Ottomans and the Mlukes until the
Ottomans actually beat the Mlukes and
around 1517 and um absorbed all of that
whole area. So the the Mlu the Ottomans
were definitely the scourge of more in
more modern times. Okay. So from around
1400 uh up until you know 1683 they're
at Vienna, right? They're surrounding
Vienna. For those hundreds of years, the
Ottomans completely devastated the
Balkans, conquered so many regions, you
know, Greece, uh, Bulgaria, Albania, all
these regions. Hungary was one of its
main enemies, but it also got conquered
for about 150 years. And, um, you know,
it, like I said, it goes all the way up
until 1683, and now they're around
Vienna again, encircling it with
200,000. Um, and I'll tell you a very
interesting story about Vienna because
it's very applicable to today.
Something's happening today about this,
but in the battle of Vienna in
1683, yeah, you have something like
200,000 Muslim Ottomans surrounding it.
And on their way, they destroyed and
devastated any everything, killing
30,000 Christian captives, etc. And um
they they were about to to enter breach
um Vienna. It was about two months into
it or even less until and right before
they did on September 12th, the king of
Poland came, John Soies III with
something like 65,000 fighters and they
were on the top of a hill and he very
clearly says this is about Christianity
and Islam and they're trying to take it
and so forth. I have a whole chapter
about that too, sort of scimitar, all
these big ones. Um and then they had you
know thunderous cavalry charge and they
defeated and and the Ottomans and lifted
the siege. And of course Vienna was
grateful very much. So since then
they've been trying to put up a monument
or a statue for Soies on that hill in
Vienna where he came down and a lot of
vianese and Austrians wanted it and of
course polls wanted and it's a way of
thanking the polls for what they did.
But the the city council of Vienna said
that's too Islamophobic and it might
offend the Muslims. When was that? This
is happening right now. This is
something actually that was just
reported like a few weeks ago. Okay. And
we're not going to have it because it it
agitates Islamophobia. And uh and then
you look into in Vienna and it's like a
bastion of Islam. I didn't know this but
or until recently there are more Muslim
students than Catholic students. And
Vienna of course was a Catholic nation.
It was it was a seat of the Holy Roman
Empire. Um which was why it was so
important to Muslims to conquer like
Rome. Today there are more Muslim
students in Vienna than in Vienna. And
constantly there's there the mosques are
being busted for teaching hate. Last
year there was a a foiled plot on a
Taylor Swift concert. Yeah. Yeah. But I
mean there's a lot. I I wrote an article
and there's so many things and you know
these students tried to shoot up a
Christian class and they said because
killing Christians get us into heaven.
That's what the Muslims said, the
students. Um but and um so so we're at
so so basically what's going on is
Vienna is willing to spit in the eyes of
the ancestors of the people who
liberated them to and to humor the the
descendants of the people who were
attacking them and who are themselves
currently criminalizing Vienna because
there's all these reports of how crime
and rape has exponentially skyrocketed
since this influx of Muslim migrants.
Okay. Yeah. Um and it's just amazing and
and and a final you know about these
battles because this is related um in
France also about a couple months ago a
couple of Muslims tried to bomb
something in Poier by tours um why
because they wanted to avenge the defeat
at the battle. You're kidding me. No
they were smarting about that still this
battle most Westerners don't even
remember. Again showing you the long
view of Muslims they won 1800 years
later. Yeah. Wow. There's the Seeing as
we're recording in America, I just read
the biography of Captain John Smith who
set up the to fight Turks. Well, yeah,
he he he set up the the the the first
successful colony at Jamestown and he
would before that he's a man from
Lincolnshire and he went to fight the
Turks in Hungary and was captured,
became a slave, was tra taken all the
way across to east eastern uh Turkey. uh
eventually escaped, walked up to Moscow,
then walked all the way across Europe
again to uh his friends in Hungary and
eventually
um actually he didn't even go home then
at that point. He went off and went on
some other adventures. Um but uh it it's
it for me it it goes to show that
actually even the founding of America
you mentioned the Barbrey Wars earlier
that there's this stuff would have would
very much have been in the imagination
of the founders of of this country as um
as we've seem to have forgotten all of
that stuff. But but isn't it ironic John
Smith I mean he's mostly famous for
what? Pocahontas. Yeah. Right. But here
even this guy has this long sorted
affair with Islam. Right. Yeah. And
since you mentioned it and since I've
been talking about history and I went up
to 1683, let me actually finish it off
with Barbrey because that's very
important. Um, people don't realize I
mean think about this. America's first
war as a nation after gaining
independence from your country uh was
was against Muslims
and Jefferson. Yeah, Jefferson. And why?
Because they were using the very same
logic that all the other Muslims that I
quoted, you know, the jihad, etc. You're
an infidel. And uh so they start
attacking and plundering American
vessels sometime in I think 1780 or
something right soon after the
revolutionary war. And um long story
short Jeff Jefferson and John Adams they
meet with the ambassador from Barbrey I
think Tripoli Abdul something you know
it's I have it in my book and they say
what have you you know we're willing to
be friends and trade. Why are you
attacking us? What have we done to you?
And then Jefferson he wrote a letter to
Congress which we still have with the
ambassador's response. And to paraphrase
it, he basically told him, "Our Quran
says and our prophet says you're our
enemy and it's our right and duty to
attack and plunder and kill you and
enslave you wherever we can find you."
And most people don't realize he was
actually paraphrasing Quran 95, which is
known in Islam as the sword verse. And
it says lay and wait and lay and wait
wherever you can find the infidel and
ambush them and kill them and enslave
them. Okay. So anyway, so it's the same
mentality, same logic. America's very
first war. It just became a nation. It
hasn't even had its first president yet,
George Washington. And it gets dragged
into eventually two wars. Okay, the
first is the barber first Barbara war in
1801 and that drags on and again in
1815. Okay. So, you know, so here, look,
we fast forwarded almost 1,200 years
since the battle of Yarmmuk, right, in
636. Now we're in 1815. And it's the
same mentality, same logic. And it's the
same thing that they tell us Islam
doesn't mean that Islam means peace. And
that's how that's how effective they've
been. They've gotten that narrative to
become dominant. Even though the long
storied past of history is very it's
it's it's an unwavering continuity of
Islamic hostility based on Islamic
teachings and you know jihad. So we'll
we'll come up to the present day but
before we do seeing as you've mentioned
the Quran I guess there's a you have
also said you're not a theologian so I I
remember but you know
um uh where do you think this comes from
within Islam and is it the behavior is
it the example of Muhammad or the
example of these first early Muslim
warriors and I think it's an important
one because we look at Islamism today
and it's clearly we talk about ISIS and
we all these the Muslim Brotherhood and
we talk about Israel and Hamas and um
it's clear that there's a there's
there's an aspect of Islam
that
is like like the the the scripture you
just cited that is uh I guess violent um
and um and there's contention there that
this idea of peaceful Muslims, moderate
Muslims
and I guess yeah I I I I'm not sure
exactly what my question here is but I
the origins of all this how it all Yeah.
Yeah. Like how much is this from the
Quran? How much is this from Muhammad?
What's your perspective on that? Yeah.
Okay. It's all you have to understand
how Islamic law works. Okay. So
according to Islam standard Islamic
teaching amongst Sunnis who are 90% of
the Muslim world um you know the twin
the twin sources of authority are the
Quran which is understood to be the
literal words of Allah and then what's
called the hadith okay plural it's a
hadith but I'm going to say hadiths to
anglicize it and um all they are are
vast volumes and volumes and volumes of
what Muhammad supposedly said and did.
Okay. And according to the Muslim, you
know, scientists as they call
themselves, you know, they rank them.
There's what's called sah, meaning it's
correct. It's authentic. He did say
this. And that takes on almost the same
value as a Quran. Okay? Mhm. And there's
a lot of that. Now, based on those two
things, hatred for the non-Muslim is
unequivocal and continuously documented.
War on them as jihad, continuously
documented. uh treating you know the
non-Muslim who gets conquered as a dimmi
which means they have to live as a
secondass citizen and pay tribute
unequivocally documented these are
totally enshrined based on the Quran and
the words of Muhammad okay his example
and Muslims the word Sunni I mentioned
them it uh the Sunni means like the
example so there a Sunni is trying to
follow the example of Muhammad so
Muhammad wage war on infidels that's
what we have to do as well so it's
unequivocally clear you know anyone a
person will tell you that no, Islam
doesn't teach violence, etc., he's
either really really ignorant or being
very very deceptive. Okay, it could be
one or the other. Um, but if you've
taken the time to study them as I have
in their original languages, and that's
another problem. If you look at the
Quran today, it's they're mistransating
it intentionally. They add words that
don't exist, you know. So, for example,
Quran 9:29 will say, which literally
says, "Fight the people of the book,"
which means Jews and Christians until
they pay tribute and feel themselves
subdued. Okay? And that's that's the
teaching that come that's what justifies
jiza. It uses the word jiza. Um a lot of
English now Quran translations say fight
the people of the book if they fight you
first. Okay. And okay so now it doesn't
look so bad. This is again defensive
war. This is just war. The original
doesn't say if they fight you first.
Says you attack them. So there's
unfortunately a lot of playing around
with Islamic scriptures intent in
intended to deceive infidels. Um but
yeah that it's it's just it's that
simple. That's what the two twin pillars
of Islamic the the Islam Islam's
authority the Quran hadith say and the
Quran is the word of God and I read the
Quran a few years ago and it what the
difficult thing for me apart from
certain of some certain of the
scriptures like the ones mentioned
already is that it says throughout it
you must take this literally and you
can't swear so so the idea of a sort of
Islamic reformation against this seems
to be tricky having said that and I'll
come come back to Europe. But I look
around the world now where I have hope
with relations between the western world
and the Islamic world is the leaders of
let's say the Emirati leaders uh where
where the the the signatories of the
Abraham Accords and I see oh actually
these are people who are taking Islamism
seriously. They recognize the problem.
They're even calling the Westerners out
for not taking it serious enough. Um the
Emiratis have been fantastic on this
particularly Muhammad bin Zed. Um For
me, the hope is that these people are
interpreting the the scripture in a
certain way that means that there will
be uh relations much improved from
everything you've described in history.
Do you think I'm I'm right to feel this
way? No, I I think there's room for
optimism for for a number of reasons.
You know, the the the hur the
insurmountable hurdle is what I just
described. Okay. The texts are so black
and white. You know, it literally says
in the Quran that if you're a Muslim,
you have to hate non-Muslims. And I've
watched cleric after cleric say things
like, "Yeah, even if you're married,
because Islam allows Muslim men to marry
Christian women or Jews." And he'll say,
"Yeah, you can marry them and have fun
with them sexually, but you have to hate
them and you have to let them know you
hate them." Okay, that's that's how much
it's so ironclad. Now, you know, and
this is the whole question about what's
a moderate Muslim. Okay, so yeah, I
don't believe in a moderate Islam
because it's just not there. It's black
and white. But I do believe in moderate
Muslims because humans are subjective
and they can do whatever they want,
right? They can believe they can just
reinterpret it their own way. They can
ignore it. I mean, so I believe you have
that. It exists. It's just it's very
hard to doctrinally justify it, okay,
against the hardliners. That's why they
always end up winning the arguments
because it goes back to what the Quran
says and what the hadith says. Okay? But
there's all kinds of leeway and and you
know, ways to get around this, I
suppose. Um but you're right a lot of
people what they don't they say we want
a pro they say we want a reformation of
Islam and what they don't get is
actually something very akin to the
Protestant reformation has been
happening and it's what led to
radicalism okay not because
Protestantism is radical but the same
methodology and I'll explain what I'm
saying Protestantism essentially uh was
you know solo scriptura we don't we're
done with clergies and whatever we just
want the Bible okay and um Islam before
for a while has always been yeah the
Quran and the Sunnah but most people
were illiterate Muslims and you had to
rely on the and the scholars and the
shakes etc and there were schools of law
and there still are which could you know
modify teachings certain ways or not
well like the Protestant Reformation you
know since modern times now the Quran is
available on the internet okay and pe
Muslims are literate and they can read
Arabic and what's happening is they're
becoming more and more going back to the
scriptures and not caring so much about
what the schools of law they're called
med say so it's a it's almost like a
solos scriptorra mentality but the but
the result is the exact opposite because
if you're a Christian who just goes by
the Bible well you're going to turn the
other cheek and you're going to love
your neighbor and you're going to
believe in monogamy etc etc if you go
strictly with what I'm talking about the
Quran and the Hadith well that's where
all the hatred comes and the violence
and basically a seventh century Bedawin
mentality I mean that's that's what's
captured there so what people really
want is not um a pro not a reformation
of Islam which I don't think is possible
they wanted an enlightenment which was
basically you know not even caring what
the scriptures say and just rising above
it and uh you know how you rationalize
that people can do whatever they want I
mean look amongst Christians you have
all kinds of different beliefs and
teachings even though one Christian will
say no the Bible says this and so of
course it can be done um but you're
going to need and the leaders you have
to remember they can do what they can do
but a lot of the you know the people are
you know Saudi Arabia is our good friend
and ally and I know they're also
sometimes part of these accords etc. But
they're also the chief disseminators of
radical Islam. Okay, they're the ones
who fund this. You know, if you go to a
mosque in in England and you find it has
radical hateful books, it's coming from
Saudi Arabia, you know. So, it's and
again, we have to contend with this idea
of taka Islam allowing deception of the
infidel as needed. Okay, so we're in a
weak phase. then we have to you know be
accommodating to them and not hate them
openly. So all of that needs to be taken
into consideration. But having said that
I think if western powers or the
non-Muslim world just dropped the act
and said look we understand your
religion we understand it has violence
and we understand this but we're not
going to tolerate it and you know in
other words call them out and stop
playing this game as if no no it's not
there. It is there let's confront it and
let's work around it. I suspect if you
were to do that then you a lot of the
problems might go away. Yeah. Because if
you just you call it out and everyone's
like actually we better behave. Yeah.
Yeah. But if you keep acting no no your
religion means peace. There's nothing
wrong with your religion. Okay. So it's
you're not addressing the problem. Well
this brings me to what's going big
scandal in my country the grooming gang
scandal where tens of thousands of young
Rotherham Rotherham. Exactly. Uh young
white underclass girls predominantly
white. Um there's some other Hindu girls
and and different groups but mainly
white have been targeted because they
are quote kafir and uh kafir or kafar is
kafir singular kafar is plural kufur
and it's still now contentious you can't
call it what it is because the
perpetrators are predominantly Pakistani
heritage uh grooming gangs um even
calling them a grooming gang isn't quite
it's the rape gang rape gangs is is what
they really are um and
um we're just sort of unable to uh call
out that that kind of stuff. We also
have we've Islamist attack after
Islamist attack. This is kind of across
Europe. It's a it's a problem and and
this is this is what I I kind of want to
your whole history. I wonder how we can
uh make it relevant to what's going on
in that because you sort of given a
historical context
and Muslims are moving to Europe on mass
in in in hugely growing Muslim
populations particularly in contrast
with a declining let's say quotequote
indigenous
population and Christianity is also on
the decline anyway amongst those. Um, so
I I I wanted your perspective on on how
we might find social
cohesion today in Europe. Sure. Um, so
let me give you some more context
because you're right, you know, the
history I I told you and there's still
elements of it that we need to talk
about to make sense of what you're
discussing. Um so one of the you know
one of the earliest motifs amongst
Islamic scholars and this goes back to
about the 8th 9th centuries was that um
you know and I hate to put it this way
but that's how they put it like white
women want it okay and white women are
desirable and they're the and I was
telling you about the Vikings bringing
slaves they wanted fair slaves this is a
well doumented thing that goes back to
Muhammad you know for during one
campaign the the campaign against it's
called Tabuk where he was supposed to
fight the Eastern Roman empires which
would be Greeks he actually tried tried
to cajul men to join him by saying don't
you want the people of yellow and and
and he talks about the women how
beautiful they are but yellow I assume
means hair a lot of people try to
understand what that means does it mean
hair fair skin whatever um so there's a
long kind of like this almost like say m
masochistic thing of presenting white
women as wanting it and just like okay
so now fast forward and what you're
talking about believe it or not because
I've looked into it very closely and the
Muslims the Pakistanis and whatnot they
use the same exact logic and they quote
that and they say, "Yeah, Islam already
told us these people want it and that's
what they're for and they like it, etc.,
etc." So, just, you know, something to
keep in back. Actual quote from
Muhammad. Yeah. In a hadith. Yeah. The
the quote is that he basically said, um,
you know, uh, don't you want the the
people of yellow, you know, like come
join me on this raid so we can get
pretty blonde women, basically. Okay.
Okay. Okay. And um but even I you know
I'm saying it starts with N but you find
iterations of this all throughout. Okay
you know most khifs people don't know
this but uh you know even amongst the
Ottomans but especially in Spain you
know their last khif was something like
99% white. Why? Because every sultan
would mate with white women you know and
he would you know be half diluted. So at
the very end a lot of these sultans were
essentially blondhaired and blue-eyed
but they're Muslim sultans right? Uh, so
this is so anyway my point is this
group. So you bring a Muslim population
that thinks this way and you put them in
England. What do you think is gonna
happen? And you teach women to be
promiscuous or whatever, you know, free
love, etc. What's going to happen? This
is going to happen obviously. Okay. Um,
as as far as you're asking me, you know,
how to get past all that. And the thing
with England and and I mean you telling
me is is the attack on sense is free
speech getting that bad because it seems
like you can't even you can't call out
like you just said you can't even call
something what it is anymore. Um it's
amazing. Yeah. I mean that's a whole
other and people being arrested and you
know it's like uh anyway so it's just
amazing to me. You know, you compare and
contrast what I've been talking about,
which is, you know, Europeans, King
Richard, speaking of England, who fought
tooth and nail to keep Islam out of
Europe, okay? And now all of a sudden,
and this is why history and doctrine is
important, because they've told us the
exact opposite of what I'm saying, which
is no, Islam is wonderful. It means
peace. What are you talking about? Let's
bring them in by the boatloads or
whatever, millions. And guess what? You
see what's happening happening because
it's just a continuum of what always
happened. So on the one hand you have
Muslims walking in perfect stuck with
their ancestors and now you have mus
westerners in perfect discontinuity with
their ancestors. You know they've just
completely reject or perhaps continuity
with the ancestors pre uh the the first
invasion from the the of Islam into
Europe. So this is like if you go back
1500 years that is do you see some sort
of parallel with that do you think or is
that a stretch? Well, no, because there
was no time in history where Islam tried
to get into Europe that they said come
on in. They just either lost and fought
like in Spain, right? Okay. But they
always resisted. So this is the first
time they So this is unprecedented
what's happening where you know you're
you're invi you're inviting them and
they're acting the same way as usual and
your people are suffering and then you
buckle down even more and you know
stifle your people and keep bringing in
more and you know it's just like what's
really going on then? Is there anywhere
else in the world outside of Europe
where there is uh where where where
Muslims and Christians and Jews have
been able to live side by side? You know
in Europe you have countries like
Albania and maybe Montenegro and well we
had in the Bosnian war we had
concentration camps with Muslims rounded
up really a great place to look. No no
but by and large those countries until
now you you can you can see Muslims and
Christians living side by side. But the
reason honestly is the Muslims are not
very Muslim and and the Christians
aren't even very Christian. In other
words, the people there are very
secular. You look at a Muslim in, you
know, in a lot of these European
countries and they just like they don't
know the first thing about I've talked
to them and they don't, you know, they
don't know the first thing about Islam
and but they're Muslim by name. So I
think that's one of the reasons that
yeah, you can have that. Look, if you
want if Muslims are gonna if Muslims are
in power and they're the dominant group
and they're upholding and following
Islamic teachings, then by nature the
non-Muslim, the Jew, the Christian is
going to have to live as a secondass
citizen. Okay? So like in Egypt for
example, you know, which was a very
Christian nation and now it's 90%
Muslim, let's say 10% Christian. Okay?
So there's constant persecution, but
there's all these laws against churches.
Okay? So, I just read a report finally
came out um you know the the numbers and
it long story short Christians are
always complaining we need churches and
they're not allowing them to build
churches and if you go back to Islamic
law Islamic teaching which I was
discussing as based on the hadith and so
forth. You're not supposed to Christians
who are conquered they can live and pay
tribute but they can't build their
churches. So until today in a modern
nation like Egypt you have that law or
kernels of it still exist. Okay. And it
came out because it finally came out
that when you do all the number
crunching, for every one church that
Christians have, Muslims have 60. If you
if you even up their numbers as
population, I mean, think about how
obvious discrimination that is. Okay?
And they're also But Egypt publicly will
tell everyone in the world, no, no, we
treat our citizens the same. Okay? They
all have the same religious freedom. But
1 to 60, that ratio is pretty, you know,
pretty telling. So, but Egyp Egypt, you
know, its constitution article 2 says we
trace our legislation to Sharia and so
it's even in their it's in the
constitution. So, as long as Muslims are
going to live, it's it's just plain and
simple. The Islamic law, Islamic
teaching is black and white and it is
divisive. It is discriminatory and it
does incite violence against the
non-Muslim. That's it. Okay. Now to what
extent Muslims are going to enforce that
or live up to it. Okay, maybe some don't
care and I in that case you can live
with them. All right, I often give a
good analogy. I try to u to understand
what a moderate Muslim is. Okay, and
it's it's I I I it's the Nazi an
analogy. Okay, which is a little, you
know, hear me out. Hear me out. Oh dear.
No, it doesn't sound so bad. Can you
hear me out? Okay,
so he went there. No, no, no. All right,
here's what I'm saying. Nazism is a body
of teachings. It's an ideology, okay?
And it has supremacy, white supremacist
ideas in it, okay? And it has other
teachings, whatever, national
socialists. They come to power. Um, and
then you got a guy like Oscar Schindler,
all right? And he was a Nazi. He was an
actual ranking Nazi. And you know his
story. He saved Jews and etc. And he
went out of his way and you know, no
small threat to himself, but he was a
Nazi. Okay. So my question to you is
what he did, his good deed, was that an
aspect of his personality of him rising
above Nazism or was he practicing a
moderate form of Nazism? Okay, I I think
you're going to tell me he just rose
above it and did not implement the, you
know, the the supremacist aspect,
killing Jews, whatever. Okay, he rose
above it. And that's how we have to
understand Muslims and moderate Muslims.
Okay, the Islam has its negative
teachings, its violence, its
divisiveness, it's hate. Okay, if a
Muslim doesn't act that way, and there I
know there are I know there's Muslims
who don't do that, okay, and they're
good people. Is that because they're
practicing moderate Islam or is it
because they rose above it? See, when
you say that, all of a sudden people
want to say, "No, no, it's a moderate
Islam." But they won't do that with
Nazism. They'll say, "No, Nazism is what
it is. It's it's a violent supremacist."
I think the the the obvious problem with
that analogy is that moderate Muslims
will who I've spoken to on this show
will rather than rising above Islam,
they'll appeal to other scripture and
then they'll say there's a there's a
contention here. There's a
contradiction. So, we're going to appeal
to this and this one where it says, you
know, they will do that. You're right.
But what I'm saying, which is not You
can't do that with Nazis. You can't
appeal to another for side of Nazism.
No, I would argue I would argue what
what's happening is they're being
disingenuous. Okay. They're they're
making an appeal saying, "Oh, no.
There's a way around this." And I'm
telling you, "No, there isn't." Okay.
So, yeah, it would be like a Nazi
telling you, "No, no, wait. There's
aspects of Nazism where where allows for
this, and you and I know there isn't."
You know, so give me an example what
they would say, for example.
Unfortunately, I'm not equipped enough
to have this argument. But I would say
that there's enough uh contradiction
within the Quran that it's it's clear
that they would have a a problem where
there might not be the same
contradictions in Nazism. It's pretty
clearcut what they thought about the
Jews. If you're okay, so if you're the
kind of Muslim who is I'm going to read
the Quran and understand it my own way
and that's fine then. Yeah, you can do
that. But to be a true Sunni Muslim,
that's not how it works. You have to
follow the interpretation, the exugesus
of the, you know, the authorities. And
all of them are unequivocal about the
topics that we're discussing because
they're so ironclad. So again, you know,
for example, there's a movement among
Muslims and it's a good movement.
They're called Quranists. What they want
to do is just the only book they look at
is the Quran and they're done with the
SE the Sunnah, the Hadith. And that
would be great because honestly a lot of
the most troubling teachings come from
the hadith, not so much the Quran. The
Quran is very poetic. Okay? And so that
would be a great thing, but they're a
tiny tiny minority. they're not even 1%
of the Muslim population. Okay? So, you
can do that and they do exist um Muslims
like that and that's more power to them.
But if you're being a standard, I'm a
Sunni Muslim who's just following the
traditions of my fathers and I belong to
one of the four med they have four
schools of law which are very very
similar. They just have nuance
differences but they agree about what
we're talking about. Execute the
apostate or punish him at least.
Blaspheming, you know, etc. Keeping
Christians and Jews suppressed, war on
the infidel. These are non-negotiables.
Okay. So, if you're get that kind of
Muslim, yeah, I mean, I can say to the
infidel, "No, no, there's there's a way
around this, but that would be like me
telling someone who's ignorant of
Nazism." And I'd be like, "No, in Nazism
there's there's, you know, there's room
for Jews and, you know, and non-arans to
live in peace." And, okay, you'll
believe it. But it's I'm just saying
that, you know, they can say whatever
they want and they can believe it and
they there can be large numbers of
Muslims who live that way, but they're
not this is not in accordance with
Islamic un mainstream Islam just like a
Nazi can say, "No, no, I I love, you
know, non-arans, but yeah, that's not in
accordance with Nazi ideology." Right.
Um, we mentioned right at the beginning
of this conversation that we would look
at your work on exposing the terrible
treatment of Christians by Muslims
around the world. Now, this has been a
an amazing long conversation so far. So,
I appreciate that uh opening I'm
breaching a new topic, but what perhaps
we can touch on some of the most recent
things and then I'll I'll I'll put
listeners to go to your to your um
reporting on your website. Um but, uh
maybe we just stick with 2025 and what's
happening. We've had some reports from
Congo, Nigeria, and even Syria, although
it's very mixed reporting on Syria, and
I'm not sure how true it is there, but
but I wondered, yeah, if you could
explain what's going on. So, you know,
the pers the persecution of Christians
and it really dovetales wonderfully with
what we're talking about because it's
again, it's part of the continuum. Uh,
the persecution of Christians by Muslims
has always been there from the very
beginning because most of Muslim lands
are in Christian territory. Um, and
that's why so many of them ended up
converting to Islam. and you have small
minorities and that's why they
disappeared in some areas. So the cops
for example who used you know the word
Coptic for example just to give you an
idea of how infused with Christianity is
you know the word Egyptian that's the
Greek word which is iiggiptos and um
when the Arab conquerors of Egypt came
they took the word for native Egyptian
Igtos but they just took the middle
syllable gip and that became
transliterated into cop for us. So it
just means Egyptian but it means
Christian because all the Egyptians were
Christians. So cop means Christian and
Egyptian. Anyway, um so they went from
being the majority almost 100% to now
they're 10% because of 14 centuries of
discrimination and you know sporadic
persecution which is well documented by
the way. Anyone who's interesting can
get a book called a sword a sword over
the Nile which is uh it's not my book
but it's really great because it's based
on the primary sources of what happened
um to the Christians of Egypt. Anyway,
what's interesting is if you fast
forward, so okay, during the attacks on
Christians of the Middle East, Egypt,
Syria, everywhere, it was again attacks
on churches, attacks on their persons,
of course, extorting money from them as
a form of Jiza tribute, enslaving their
women and children, etc. That's still
going on, okay? And it's in all the
Islamic worlds to different degrees. U
maybe you've heard of a group called
Open Doors. Um, okay. Okay. So, it's a
humanitarian Christian international
organization which has been around for
decades and every c every year they
publish a report. It's called the world
watch list and it ranks the 50 worst
nations to be a Christian where
Christians are most persecuted. And I
look I write about it every year and you
know it habitually 37 38 of the 50 are
Muslim nations. And I mean that to me is
talk about telling right? It's like
almost every Muslim nation there is a
foreign a kind of Christian persecution.
Some are worse than others. Okay, now we
can go to Africa. That's the worst.
Subsaharan Africa that according to a
lot of uh human rights groups there's a
genocide in Nigeria and and I follow it
closely and I think every week I have to
read about dozens of Christians being
killed by Muslims. Uh and of course the
media they they tell you no no no this
is a this is about climate you know
change. One group is being pushed out
and they're attacking another group.
They actually do that. Well media are
actually they do that actually. Yeah.
And they don't tell you that the ones
being pushed out are all Muslims and the
ones being killed are all Christians.
Okay. No, they actually do that. So what
what's happening then in Nigeria? Uh you
have Muslim groups. First you had the
terrorist group called Boo Haram, which
means Western education is a sin. And
all they've been doing is attacking and
killing Christians. But now you have
what's called the fani. They're
herdsmen, okay? Who live and and c they
graze their cattle and they're attacking
the Christians who are sedentry. Okay.
And they're just butchering and killing
them and taking over their land and of
course also engaging in destroying their
churches and other the hallmarks of
attacks on Christianity that emphasize
that there's an ideological component.
But if you talk to the professionals and
the media is has nothing to do with
religion. It literally it's climate
change because the pastoral fani are
being pushed out and they're just they
need more land. So they attack these but
for some reason they only attack
Christians uh never Muslim sedentry
areas. Yeah. And what how exactly does
climate change force them to kill and
Exactly. is where's the motivation? No a
lot of I remember the I think it was the
Irish president who came out and made a
big scene about no this is climate
change. Don't talk about Islam. It's
Islam means peace. And this was like a
year ago. And uh it's like mostly
peaceful climate change. Yeah. And then
the next day, you know, Muslims attack a
church in Nigeria and kill like 50
people and and all of a sudden that too
is not about religion. Um I mean they
I've really followed this and the the
the little the acrobatics they play to
just make you think this isn't about
religion are amazing even though it's so
obvious about rel I once quoted a nun a
black nun from Nigeria who's like you
know it's it's hard for us not to
believe this is about religion when
they're dressed in black screaming Allah
Akbar and break the cross you know and
you tell me it's about climate change.
So, so that's Nigeria, but in subsaharan
in Nigeria, do we have a sense of the
death to talk? Um, I've seen various
reports and it apparently got really,
really bad starting around 2009. Um, and
has been going on and off, but I would
say maybe
70,000. Yeah. Just butchered. And what
has the Christian response been to that?
The Nigerian Christian or Nigerian or
the greater Christian? the greater
Christian response is it's not
happening, you know, and there's nothing
to see here. You know, black lives
apparently only matter if they're not
Christian, you know, it's it's really
it's it's one of those things where if
it was the opposite, if this was, let's
say, Muslims being killed by Christians,
this would be on the news nonstop,
everyone would know about it, you know,
but such as it is, uh, and and again,
why why do you think that the the
Christians don't care about this? I
mean, I think to a great degree a lot of
them don't know, so they're basically
just misled by the media that they
trust. You know, Fox News isn't going to
talk about this either, right? So, for
whatever reason, this isn't a topic for
them. But I'd have hoped that like the
Church of England or the leaders of the
churches who do know about it, they
absolutely know about it would be every
single day. Every single church service
they'd be but you know also a lot of
these churches don't want to antagonize
Muslims and they're more excited and
more proud about holding hands with a
Muslim imam and showing their wonderful
you know ecumenicism reach out. So a lot
of them don't want to Pope Francis you
know he puts he writes encyclicals about
this and that. How about Christians
being butchered left and right? you
know, um, any word on that? Nope. We
don't want to talk. So, again, you have
to understand that amongst Christians of
all denominations, there's this
political correctness, this need to like
make Muslims look good and, you know,
etc., etc. So, they don't want to talk
about it. It's uh if you talk about
Christian persecution, you totally
overthrow the narrative that they've
been trying to build because, you know,
if you talk about Muslims attacking
Israel, okay, it kind of makes sense
because they're the underdog. They're
angry. They're fighting back. Okay? But
if you look at the Muslim world and you
realize Muslims are dominant there and
they're persecuting their tiny
minorities simply because of religious
differences because they're not Muslims,
then you start realizing, okay, so
Muslims are just u intolerant and uh
maybe this isn't about what's happening
in Israel. Maybe this is just something
among them. Um so that I've noticed and
I've been following this and writing
about it a lot. Muslim persecution of
Christians has been one of those most no
topics. We don't want to we don't want
to go there cuz it's because there's no
rationale to it. Muslims attack Israel.
Muslim bomb western cities. Oh, they
have grievances. Oh, this. Oh, that. But
if you find it's an institutionalized
discrimination and persecution of
minorities simply because they're not
Muslim. How do you get around that?
Well, the way you get around it is you
don't talk about it. And you put that
back to that Quran that you cited
earlier about the people of the book.
And Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's that's one
of the verses. Uh yeah. Fight the people
of the book. Quran uh 9:29, but there's
others in the hadith telling you how to
treat Christians. If you see a Christian
or Jew, you have to push them against
the wall, don't say salam, don't say
hello uh to Christians and Jews. Um all
sorts of things. You have to hate them
even though you have to live with them,
etc., etc. So, yeah, it all traces back
to these scriptural injunctions. Uh so,
we've covered Nigeria. Um and you've
written about what's going on in Congo.
Um what that's also come up in the news
this year. Yeah. Yeah, I know. Well, I
think a month ago or so, maybe two
months ago, they entered a church and
found 70 decap decapitated Christians.
Okay. And it was by an Islamic terror
group, which funny enough goes by the
its name is something democracy. Okay.
Uh it's it's part of this group called
uh I I forget, but if you look it up,
something democracy, and they're a rebel
group, and it sounds like they're
leftist, and maybe they have leftist
elements. Um, but they also have a
jihadist wing who does what that, you
know, decapitated 70 Christians. Again,
if you look into it, you know, if you
dig in, you're going to see the
hallmarks. Oh, this is about ideology.
It's about hatred for Christians. Okay,
the narrative, no, this is just some
rebel group and those are just poor
innocent victims that were caught up in
the war and and and it gets very, you
know, it's very hygienic and we don't
talk about the religious element, okay?
You get if you're following the
mainstream media, right? But if you, you
know, look into it as I do and I look at
all the sources, it's very clear what's
going on. Is it is it worse? You said
earlier it's worse than Africa, right?
Is it worse in Africa because that's the
continent where most Christians and
Muslims are living side by side? That's
a good question. And I think that is
part of it. Well, I guess Europe more
probably. Yeah. But I mean, for example,
Nigeria is literally 50/50. You know,
it's 50% Christian, 50% Muslim. And
isn't that interesting that it's like a
full-blown civil war essentially going
on over there? Um there's this idea
about you know Islamop Muslim
populations as it grows and this is sort
of historically demonstrable but you
know if it's a small population let's
say 1% which is like America yeah
they're just going to be sort of vocal
kind of from a you know my rights type
thing like leftist groups let's say but
when they become like let's say 10% then
like in Europe in certain countries and
cities then you get a lot of criminality
and you get these enclaves and no go
zones. So I've heard by various sources
um and then when it grows let's say 50%
now you have a war you have a full jihad
okay when it keeps growing and now it's
70 80% then the you know the infidel is
completely suppressed look at Saudi
Arabia you can't even you can't even
have a church or anything there um or
they're suppressed you know tremendously
uh so it's actually it's it's very
unwavering and for Europe it's
unfortunate because these numbers I saw
a pew poll say like in 2050 you know
Germany Muslims are going to like 40% of
the population. I mean, at that point,
yeah, it's going to be like Nigeria.
It's going to be a war because why not?
Uh I I I mentioned uh Syria. Um what
there's mixed reporting here, so I'm I'm
hesitant to say that I am too. Yeah.
Right. You agree with my Yeah. It's very
It's very confusing what's really going
on. Sometimes you hear it's Christian,
sometimes you hear it's not. It's, you
know, Aloise and it's, yeah, it's right.
We have to wait for this, you know,
smoke to settle kind of. Yeah. Um, well,
I encourage uh listeners and viewers to
go to your web page where you have all
of this. I mean, I couldn't quite
believe it when I went on because it's
you've been documenting these attacks on
Christians for many, many, many years.
2012, I think. No, no, it's 2011. Sorry.
Okay. So, well over a decade. And as far
as I found and including Christian
websites, this is the the most thorough
documentation. Thank you. Um and it's
it's pretty uh shocking stuff and
perhaps something that we can
go into on another conversation. Um but
um Raymond, before we close out, we've
covered so much and we've we've swept
through 1400 years of history um and
couldn't obviously possibly
uh complete every sentence. Um but is
there anything you want to add before we
close this out um about everything we've
discussed? Any important ingredients you
think I might have skimmed over too
quickly? No, I just, you know, to, you
know, to cap it off is just really to
emphasize that there's such a, you know,
a gap in people's knowledge and it's by
design. You know, this isn't just
ignorance because whatever. It's been
for decades building up where
information, like I said, fake history,
which is more potent in many ways than
fake news um has been like accelerating.
And so people really need to um educate
themselves and don't look to the
professionals because you know they're
not going to do it because a lot of them
and a lot of them maybe even agree with
me but they have a career and they don't
want to lose their job. You know what I
mean? So a lot of that so I think you
just have to independently educate
yourself about the truth about the
history and about the doctrine of Islam.
And uh if you do that you know it'll all
fall into play. And I'm not trying to
promote anger or hatred. My thing is I
believe the more we have truth the more
we can act on it and the better. But if
truth is suppressed, then there's no
remedy because you can't fix something
until you acknowledge the issue. Yeah.
You know, and if you just let it fester
and boil and simmer over, well, that's
just even worse. So, the number one
thing I would just tell people to
objectively educate themselves on these
topics and I think everything else will
fall into place. Yeah. You've mentioned
a couple of your books. Are there uh any
others that you want pe listeners and
viewers to know about? And um where can
they find you online? your social media
and website and so my website is
basically my name raymond Ibrahim.com
and there you'll get all my articles my
videos I make YouTube videos too you can
see me there and I have social media
links to to the ones even though most of
them I'm shadowbanned on because nobody
sees anything that I post they tell me
um but the books I would say if you want
to do what I just said educate yourself
the number one book that I wrote would
be Sword and Scimitar 14 centuries of
war between Islam because I give the
barebone theology and doctrine that you
need to understand about Islam without
going into every detail and then I give
the history that we just discussed and I
really document it and I go all the way
up until the present and show the
parallels. Um so I would you know that
would be the book that I would uh
primarily suggest for anyone. Yeah. Um
Raymond I would like to say it was a
pleasure speaking of you but frankly
it's it's been it's been hard uh brutal
uh history and particularly what's going
on right now is is really well try being
me sometimes.
Um, Raymond Ibrahim, thank you so much
for speaking with me and my pleasure. We
must do it again. I enjoyed it. Yes.